madame la ministre les chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée
pourtant lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique qui est le renforcement de la
résilience face à ses effets dans la
discussion générale
la parole est d'abord à madame barbara
pompili ministre de la transition
écologique
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président lugo
madame la présidente
prima mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs bonjour à toutes
et à tous quelle transition écologique
voulons nous pour notre pays je crois
que c'est aujourd'hui la question
centrale celle de la méthode de la
vitesse des moyens celle du concret car
il n'y a au fond plus d'opposition
frontale au sein de la société quant au
diagnostic
nous savons tous que chaque jour chaque
heure chaque minute qui passe rend
l'urgence climatique plus forte
nous savons tous que le dérèglement
abîme partout la nature et les humains
que ce soit en amazonie qui émet
désormais plus de carbone qu'elle danse
équestre où que ce soit ici dans nos
communes nos maisons nos champs nos
forêts où nous subissons avec une
intensité croissante inondations
sécheresses gel canicule et les
incendies
face à cela il n'y a qu'une seule issue
chez nous et partout dans le monde
la neutralité carbone la sortie de la
civilisation des énergies fossiles le
plus vite possible et dans des
conditions soutenables pour tous le fait
qu'il existe un consensus puissant à ce
sujet est en soi une grande victoire car
c'est le préalable à l'action
mais nous savons aussi que cette phase
celle de l'action n'a rien d'aisé
parce qu'il s'agit justement d'une
grande bascule de sortir d'un modèle qui
structurent nos vies depuis des
décennies il s'agit d'interroger nos
habitudes nos modes de vie de passer des
paroles et des constats aux actes ce que
propose ce texte
c'est donc un chemin pour réussir ce
défi et ce chemin c'est celui d'une
écologie qui frappent à la porte des
francs
c'est qu'ils s'immiscent dans nos
quotidiens pour intégrer pleinement le
modèle français
c'est à dire notre économie notre
manière de travailler notre habitat
notre alimentation
nos déplacements notre éducation tout en
fait
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs l'écologie est une chance et
non une contrainte et dans quelques
années nous réaliserons combien ce texte
a fait bouger les lignes et permis
d'accélérer cas nous car nous respirons
un air plus pur dans nos grandes villes
nous vivrons dans des logements mieux
isolés nous ne verrons plus la nature
être systématiquement dévoré par le
béton nous aurons une alimentation plus
diversifiée et des modes de consommation
plus vertueux bien sûr pour y arriver
pour faire advenir cette france du 21ème
siècle dont je veux vous parler
nous devons dépasser les obstacles
bourthes bousculer certaines idées
reçues et avancer ensemble et je dis
ensemble car je crois que c'est
profondément ce dont notre pays a besoin
car devant le changement climatique et
la dégradation de la biodiversité
il ne peut plus y avoir de parti ou de
polémique lorsque la maison brûle on ne
regarde pas ailleurs et on affronte le
défi est relevé ensemble cet immense
défi de notre génération nous ici dans
cet hémicycle et au-dehors partout dans
chaque ville et chaque village c'est
l'occasion de retrouver ce que nous
avions peut-être oublier un temps là
venir partager un héritage aux enfants
de cette république d'où qu'ils viennent
et quoi qu'ils fassent
oui mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices
et sénateurs
je crois que l'écologie est une réponse
à une grande part des maux contemporains
de notre pays
et si vous en doutez j'ai 150 preuve de
cela ils s'appellent muriel nicolas vita
malik pierre ou mélanie ils viennent de
métropole des outre mer des grandes
villes des petits villages de partout de
tous les coins de france
ils sont agriculteurs cadres retraités
lycéens et bien d'autres situations
sociales et pendant neuf mois ils sont
venus prêter directement leur concours à
la république ils ont fait vivre ce beau
mot de citoyennes et de citoyens dans ce
qu'il a de plus sincère de plus juste de
plus noble étudier un problème débattre
proposer avec toujours au coeur le sens
de l'intérêt général
l' envie d'être utile au pays le goût de
changer les choses pour le mieux et je
crois que c'est une grande bouffée d'air
démocratique dont notre pays avait là
aussi bien besoin parce que si les 150
nous laisse un héritage écologique
majeure qui va bien au delà de ce seul
projet de loin je veux aussi redire ici
ma fierté devant leur héritage
démocratique car avant la petite musique
monte que notre démocratie était fatigué
souffrant d'un manque de légitimité que
les citoyens avaient déserté la
politique qu'ils n'avaient plus
d'intérêt que pour eux et plus pour la
chose commune la res publica
cette convention citoyenne cet exercice
inédit apporte une première réponse
elle montre que les femmes et les hommes
dans ce pays veulent s'engager qu'ils
veulent participer concourir aux grandes
décisions qui structurent l'avenir du
pays qu'ils ont soif de connaissance de
débat et c'est une force immense parce
que je crois que ça sera un problème
aussi complexe que la transition
nous avons besoin de tout le monde à
bord
l'intelligence collective ce n'est pas
qu'un mot ou un concept marketing
c'est le sens même d'une assemblée et si
rien jamais ne remplacera le parlement
démocratiquement élu dans son rôle
souverain de législateurs je crois qu'il
ne faut pas avoir peur des citoyens de
leur force d'innovation de l'inventivité
de leur hauteur de vue oui la démocratie
représentative est le moteur de notre
pays et en tant qu ancien parlementaire
j'y suis viscéralement attaché chacune
et chacun d'entre vous le sait mais elle
peut s'enrichir de cette démocratie
participative et je m'étonne de voir que
certains semblent se sentir menacés dans
leur légitimité par des citoyens qui
réfléchissent et propose
car oui cette expérience inédite le
démontre la démocratie participative
renforce et affermi nos institutions et
elle apporte un nouveau regard dont on
sort collectivement grandi et d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour saluer les membres
nombreux de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat qui ont décidé de prolonge
leur engagement en se présentant aux
prochaines élections la boucle est
bouclée
alors maintenant c'est à vous qu'il
revient naturellement de poursuivre
cette dynamique enclenchée et je sais
tout ce que ce temps du parlement à
d'important pour améliorer et préciser
la loi pour faire naître des consensus
pour passer de 150 citoyens à 67
millions de françaises et de français
car notre génération ne peut plus être
celle du renoncement de l'inaction de la
petitesse de vue nous savons et nous
n'avons aucune excuse
alors oui ce texte que j'ai l'honneur de
vous présenter enrichi par le travail à
l'assemblée
c'est une nouvelle pierre de cette
république écologique pour notre pays
une ride
une république qui n'hypothèque plus
l'avenir de ses enfants une république
qui ne sourit plus le monde mais le
préserve une république forte qui
protège et qui accompagne et c'est toute
l'ambition de ce projet de loi je
parlais d'intégrer l'écologie dans le
modèle français pour l'ensemble des
enfants de notre pays la vie de citoyens
commencent à l'école de la république et
c'est pourquoi avec ce projet de loi
nous faisons entrer largement l'écologie
dans les salles de classe pour former
les écocitoyens de demain
mais au delà pour chacune et chacun tout
au long de sa vie nous donnons enfin les
moyens d'être acteur d'une consommation
responsable et vertueuse connaître le
coût environnemental des produits
transformés la publicité s'est amorcé un
sérieux virage vis-à-vis du modèle de
surconsommation qui règne en maître
depuis beaucoup trop longtemps
voilà mesdames et messieurs destinatrice
les sénateurs tout l'enjeu du titre un
portait la transition écologique au
coeur de notre modèle économique
mobiliser les milliards d'euros de la
commande publique avec des clauses
environnementales obligatoire adapter
notre code minier aux enjeux écologiques
mobiliser les instances de
représentation des salariés
oui même si l'ambition des articles
portent sur cette question a été réduite
lors de l'examen au coni en commission
je continue de croire que l'entreprise
peut être le lieu d'une démocratie
sociale et écologique
voilà l'esprit du titre 2 et je vous
parlais à l'instant d'une république
écologique qui protège qui peut oui je
le dis sauver des vies
le savez chaque année dans notre pays
quarante mille personnes meurent du fait
de la pollution de l'air principalement
liés à la circulation automobile
c'est une des principales causes de
mortalité évitable en france avec
l'alcool et le tabac ce sont des
maladies au long cours qui pèse sur la
vie de tous les jours et face à cette
urgence sanitaire sociale écologique
nous agissons en responsabilité oui
demain dans toutes les grandes villes de
france
il y aura des zones à faibles émissions
pour y limiter la circulation des
véhicules les plus polluants
à ce titre je regrette que la portée de
l'article 27a été réduite lors de
l'examen en commission car oui c est des
feux généraliser ce sera autant de
maladies respiratoires épargné à nos
enfants et autant de vies sauvées et
c'est l'ambition du titre iii
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
dessinateur l'écologie c'est souvent du
bon sens et c'est l'esprit de ce texte
et mettre un terme à cette hérésie qui
consiste à prendre l'avion alors que le
train est là en moins de 2h30 c'est du
bon sens arrêté de couler la nature sous
le béton c'est du bon sens arrêter de
construire des centres commerciaux au
milieu des champs c'est du bon sens et
cette lutte contre l'artificialisation
qui nous amène à diviser par deux son
rythme c'est tout simplement la
naissance d'une écologie des territoires
dont nous avons tout à gagner car depuis
trop longtemps notre pays a vécu sur
cette idée fausse qu'on pouvait agrandir
la ville avaler les espaces naturels et
agricoles sans cesse et que tout irait
bien
cette machine infernale n'a fait que
contribuer au déclin de la biodiversité
à l'augmentation de la dépendance à la
voiture et au sentiment d'oubli ou
d'exclusion d'une partie de la
population
alors oui en sang nous y mettons un
terme et il était plus que temps
il était aussi largement temps de
s'occuper de la vie quotidienne des
millions de foyers français qui vivent
dans des passoires thermiques et
touchant l'été glacial l'hiver toujours
dispendieux et émettant massivement du
co2 pour se chauffer je vais le dire
simplement cette situation n'a que trop
duré alors là aussi avec cette loi avec
ce titre iv nous interdisons la mise en
location de ces passoire pour conduire
les propriétaires à réaliser des
rénovations de qualité et grâce aux
travaux de l'assemblée nationale nous
avons dorénavant une trajectoire claire
et précise pour y arriver en commençant
par les classes j'ai dès 2025 les plus
consommatrices jusqu'au classe e
je regrette à ce titre mais je pense
qu'on pourra en rediscuter que le sénat
ait souhaité reculer cette échéance qui
concerne la classe e de 2034 à 2040
car nous ne laissons pas les
propriétaires seul je suis fier que ce
texte ce soit enrichi à l'assemblée des
accompagnateurs rénovation pour soutenir
les ménages de la conception des projets
à la réalisation
c'est un grand pas en avant pour aller
convaincre ceux qui hésitaient encore et
je sais combien s'engager dans des
travaux importants peut inquiéter
soyons francs nous demandons un effort à
des millions de propriétaires et je
crois que le minimum que nous leur
devons c'est de la prévisibilité de la
cohérence c'est d'entretenir un climat
de confiance le seul à même de nous
faire progresser
c'est pourquoi la loi fixe dorénavant un
principe d'engagement financier de
l'état qui grave dans le marbre la
garantie d'un reste à charge faible tout
cela mesdames et sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs c'est l'objet du titre iv
avec ce texte nous ouvrons également une
nouvelle étape dans la manière dont
notre pays se nourrit nous amplifions la
transition et agro écologiques pour les
territoires les humains et notre santé
nous luttons plus fort que jamais contre
la déforestation apportées nous laissons
le choix
à chacune et chacun d'un menu végétarien
dans les cantines scolaires et j'ai bien
noté que vous aviez supprimée en
commission la généralisation du menu
hebdomadaire végétarien alors que
l'évaluation de cette mesure est
positive j'ai cette conviction et je
tiens à la partager avec vous notre
société évolue sur ces questions vite et
fort et notre rôle notre responsabilité
c'est aussi d'accompagner l'évolution de
la société sur ce sujet tout en
soutenant l'excellence agroalimentaire
dans notre pays c'est d'offrir un choix
juste permettant à ceux qui mangent de
la viande d'en consommer de meilleure
qualité permettant de soutenir les
producteurs locaux et permettant de
consommer avec responsabilités voilà ce
qu'est l'esprit du titre 5
mesdames et messieurs dessinatrice et
les sénateurs dans cette transformation
majeure de notre pays je crois que la
justice loin d'être un problème fait
partie de la solution
alors avec cette loi nous renforçons
notre droit
notre justice celle du peuple français
qui ne tolère plus les dépôts sauvages
les pollution volontaire
les destructions de la nature prémédité
chaque génération a ses lignes
directrices
voici les nôtres diligence et sévérité
contre ceux qui portent atteinte à
l'environnement en commission vous avez
souhaité supprimer le terme d' écocide
le réservant au droit international
pourtant oui lorsqu'on détériore dans la
durée notre écosystème ont comme et bien
un écocide voilà le contenu du titre 6
et l'enfant de ce combat pour notre
planète pour notre future demande de
garder le cap sur le temps long sur un
temps qui dépassent nos mandats propre
et nos responsabilités et c'est là le
signe de la maturité de notre démocratie
savoir nous assurer que nos décisions se
déploie et que nos efforts payent alors
ce texte que je vous présente
aujourd'hui est enrichi d'un nouveau
titre cette apportée par le travail des
députés qui vient transformer notre
gouvernance climatique et l'évaluation
de la mise en oeuvre de cette loi tous
les ans par le haut conseil pour le
climat et la cour des comptes
c'est un bon moyen de nous assurer
ensemble que notre oeuvre
transformatrices se prolonge
oui cette loi est riche dense oui cette
loi amène beaucoup d'évolutions attendu
espéré parfois même oublié oui elle est
une nouvelle pierre pour notre
république et je dis nouvelles pierres
parce que cette loi n'est pas seule elle
s'accompagne du courage de mettre fin à
des grands projets date et est
incompatible avec un projet écologique
que ce soit l'aéroport de notre dame des
landes europa city la montagne d'or ou
encore le terminal t4 de roissy elle
vient avec un plan de relance historique
qui consacre 30 milliards d'euros à la
décarbonation de notre économie
elle vient avec des grandes lois que
vous avez voté qui ont été votées lors
de ce quinquennat pour les nouvelles
mobilités pour la lutte contre le
gaspillage pour l'énergie et le climat
elle s'insère dans notre mobilisation
internationale de chaque instant qui
fera demain de l'europe
la première puissance écologique de la
planète alors voilà mesdames et les
sénatrices et messieurs les sénateurs à
présent ce texte est le vôtre
il est votre pour continuer à amplifier
le travail entamé par les 150
doyenne citoyens ils les vôtres pour
faire vivre notre démocratie relever ce
grand défi de notre génération y les
vôtres pour enclencher plus vite
partout la transformation écologique
dont notre pays a tant besoin et je sais
qu ensemble ça a déjà un peu commencé
nous y arriverons
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à madame marthe
a26 drac rapporteur de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire du
développement durable pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame monsieur les présidents des
commissions saisies au fond mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs est rapporteur
pour avis mes chers collègues nous
débutons aujourd'hui l'examen de ce
projet de loi et je crois pouvoir dire
que l'ensemble des groupes politiques se
réjouit du retour des préoccupations
environnementales dans notre agenda
législatif issue de la convention
citoyenne a inspiré des 149 propositions
qui en ont résulté
ce projet de loi est apparu intéressant
mais souvent inaboutie et parfois en
trompe l'oeil avec une idée mais sans
portée normative et bien souvent dans la
reprise la prolongation est le
complément de mesures déjà adoptées voir
entrer en vigueur face à ces paradoxes
le sénat a décidé de pleinement joué le
jeu nous avons donc rencontré un grand
nombre d'acteurs afin de les écouter de
cerner leurs attentes et de recueillir
leurs propositions pour pouvoir
clarifier enrichir et compléter ce texte
ce travail de fond est débutée il ya
plusieurs mois s'est appuyé sur deux
principes directeurs la clarté de la loi
pour tous particulièrement lorsqu'elle
vient toucher notre vie quotidienne
l'acceptabilité des mesures d'un point
de vue social et notamment pour nos
concitoyens les plus modestes
en effet à l'instar de nombreux
collègues j'ai cherché à réconcilier les
transition écologique social et
économique
c'est à dire améliorer l' ambition
environnementale des mesures qui nous
ont été soumises par le gouvernement et
nos collègues députés tout en prêtant
une attention constante aux conséquences
de ce qui nous est proposé sur la
société car la transition écologique
doit se faire avec l'ensemble des
français le texte
de nos travaux de commissions sur lequel
nous discutons aujourd'hui est le reflet
de ce travail au long cours et des
équilibres nouveau que nous avons
cherché à construire ou à conforter ce
texte de commission est l'oeuvre d'un
véritable travail collectif
croisant les expertises de plusieurs
commissions et je tiens une nouvelle
fois salué l'ensemble des collègues
rapporteur et rapporteur pour avis
concernant les articles dont j'avais la
charge le texte s'organise désormais
autour de trois axes principaux
d'abord fixer un cap clair pour engager
durablement notre économie dans la
transition bas carbone
je pense notamment aux modifications
adoptées sur l'affichage environnemental
sur la régulation de la publicité ou
encore sur l'éco blanchiment
ensuite faire le trait d'union entre la
vie quotidienne des français la
structure de notre économie et nos
engagements internationaux
je fais ici référence aux mesures
relatives au vrac dans les grandes et
moyennes surfaces aux compléments
apportés à la loi geiq au soutien au
déploiement des infrastructures
nécessaires au réemploi ou encore à la
vente à emporter
enfin il s'agissait aussi de garantir
l'effectivité l'efficacité des
dispositions de ce texte
c'était l'objet de nos amendements pour
mieux territorialisée le pouvoir de
police concernant la publicité en
renonçant à la décentralisation
systématique
je pense également à tout le travail
effectué sur la protection judiciaire de
l'environnement où nous avons cherché à
rééquilibrer le quantum des peines
proposées et à sécuriser le dispositif
pénal sanctionnant les atteintes graves
aux milieux physiques vous voyez malama
ministre le sénat a pleinement joué son
rôle et vous propose aujourd'hui de
discuter sur la base d'un texte dans
l'ambition et l'efficacité sont
renforcées je forme le voeu que ces
discussions que nous engageons pour les
deux semaines à venir se déroule dans un
souci constant de la préservation de
notre environnement
le renforcement de notre économie face à
la crise que nous traversons
sans oublier évidemment le volet social
que ce texte porte
j'espère que le gouvernement saura
répondre de la manière la plus
constructive possible aux propositions
que le lit feront les sénateurs vous
l'avez compris face à l'urgence
climatique nous devons collectivement
nous employer à faire appliquer ce texte
le plus rapidement possible je forme le
voeu
nous puissions débattre sereinement et
sérieusement dans les prochaines
semaines
je vous remercie merci la parole est
maintenant monsieur pascal martin
rapporteur de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire du
développement durable également pour 4
minutes
le président madame la ministre madame
et monsieur les présidents des
commissions saisies au fond
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs et
rapporteur pour avis mes chers collègues
ma collègue martha de cidre ac vient à
l'instant de le rappeler nous ne sommes
pleinement engagés dans l'examen de ce
texte et je salue également le travail
partenarial avec les commissions
concernées aux travaux préparatoires ont
mis en lumière un paradoxe évident sur
ce texte
si le retour au premier plan des
préoccupations environnementales dans
notre agenda législatif est un symbole
majeur que je salue le texte qui nous
étaient soumis compte contenter peu de
personnes en l'état et ces mesures sont
inégales tant du point de vue de leurs
effets climatiques que de leurs
normativité entre les renoncements
inavoués les ajouts opportun les mesures
ambitieuses et certaines fausses bonnes
idées
il n'a pas été simple de faire le tri et
il faut souvent regarder dans le détail
et lever le voile sur des mesures dont
l'effet peut paraître très positif pour
l'environnement mais dans les faits se
révéler contre-productif à court ou à
moyen et même à long terme
par ailleurs je regrette que le
parlement est à se prononcer dans la
précipitation sur deux réformes majeures
qui sont à l'étude depuis des années et
qui auraient chacun mérité un examen
parlementaire chacune pardon méritait un
examen parlementaire dédiée
je pense à la réforme du code minier et
à la réforme de la gestion du recul du
trait de côte
ceci étant rappelé n'allez pas croire
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
qu'il s'agit d'une critique univoque des
avancées sont permises et si nous votons
ce texte nous donnerons davantage de
levier à nos concitoyens et à nos
collectivités pour accélérer la
transition écologique soutenir le
mouvement de relocalisation industrielle
avec la réforme du code minier
renforcer la protection des écosystèmes
sensibles est mieux maîtrisée
l'empreinte carbone de notre
alimentation
pour ma part j'ai d'abord oeuvré dans le
sens d'un rehaussement de l'ambition
environnementale du texte que nous
pourrons continuer à enrichir en séance
je pense par exemple à l'entrée en
vigueur anticipée deux ans concernant le
verdissement des contrats de concession
même si nous n'avons pas pu aller aussi
loin que je leur ai souhaité sur la
question de l'insertion
je pense aussi et surtout aux maisons
innovantes et ambitieuses que nous avons
introduite en commission au service du
renforcement de la lutte contre la
déforestation a porté ensuite j'ai
cherché à conforter nos collectivités
comme acteur majeur de la transition
écologique en leur donnant des outils
pour y parvenir les modifications
introduites en commission avec mon
collègue jean françois rapin sur le
recul du trait de côte qui vise à créer
un droit d'option pour nos collectivités
témoigne de ce souci et nous attendons
des engagements clairs madame la
ministre sur le financement de cette
extension de compétences qui ne dit pas
son nom
je pense aussi au travail effectué sur
la stratégie nationale des aires
protégées et sur l'hyper fréquentation
des espaces protégés
enfin j'ai tenu à mieux concilier
transition écologique justice sociale et
développement économique
je pense par exemple au travail que nous
avons effectué sur les engrais azotés en
mettant en place un accompagnement fort
des agriculteurs afin de ne pas
compromettre leur capacité à réaliser la
transition agro environnementales
à terme je pense lui généralement aux
mesures qui visent à mieux
territorialisée notre politique
alimentaire vous voyez madame la
ministre nous avons répondu présent où
l'on ne nous attendait pas forcément et
il est indéniable que le texte dont nous
débutons l'examen aujourd'hui est plus
ambitieux que celui qui nous étaient
soumis je n'aurais en conclusion qu'une
question à vous poser à ce stade madame
la ministre
allez vous saisir les propositions que
nous vous faisons afin de mieux
territorialisée notre politique de lutte
contre le changement climatique est
donné les moyens de collectivités pour
promouvoir une écologie de l'ain
elie jans territoriale vous remercie de
votre attention merci la parole est
maintenant monsieur philippe tabarot
rapporteur de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire du
développement durable pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mesdames messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues urgences écologiques
sanitaires économiques sont elles
conciliables
voilà la vraie question à laquelle nous
aurons à répondre pendant ces deux
semaines de débats
j'ai l'espoir de croire que nous pouvons
a lié ces trois ambitions la protection
de l'environnement la viabilité
économique et le progrès et la justice
sociale encourager convaincre stimuler
et ne pas avoir uniquement la solution
de l'interdît de la punition de la
culpabilisation
en france nous avons des marges de
progrès notamment dans les transports
avec 32 % des émissions celles sur
lesquelles je me suis investie comme mes
collègues ont ressenti global à la
première lecture de ce projet de loi peu
aboutie est plutôt mitigé vous tenter de
contenter tout le monde
à l'image du en même temps que vous
affectionnez temps mais ce texte a tout
de même des conséquences très
importantes sur de nombreux secteurs de
notre économie cela convoque une
responsabilité celle de le transformer
en parti et d'améliorer ce qui doit
l'être
le tout en excluant les points marquants
d'écologie punitive nous ne ferons pas
accepter cette nouvelle ambition
écologique par la contrainte
personne ne doit se sentir ajustements
pénalisée par les mesures écologiques
décider sinon nous échouerons bonnet
rouge gilet jaune
explorons enfin le chemin vers des
mesures de soutien
en somme une vision positive et
incitative de la transition
bien sûr nous aurions pu constater
seulement une mauvaise partition
toutefois nous avons fait le choix de
jouer le jeu ça a été précisé par mes
collègues en étant responsable et force
de proposition dès lors la difficulté de
notre exercice consiste donc madame la
ministre à vous sensibiliser sur
l'intérêt que le gouvernement a
travaillé de manière pragmatique avec le
sénat nous avons envisagé de multiples
options tenant compte des crises
sanitaires sociales et économiques
selon trois axes principaux fixer un cap
clair tout d'abord garantir
l'acceptabilité faire le trait d'union
entre la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens la transition écologique et
nos engagements
j'insisterai sur quelques volées sur les
transports d'abord en ce qui concerne le
déploiement des zones à faibles
émissions mobilité nous voulons redonner
de la souplesse aux collectivités
territoriales en ce qui concerne
l'accompagnement la décarbonation du
secteur il ne s'agit pas d'opposer les
modes mais au contraire de les associer
pour les voyageurs nous proposons
d'appliquer un taux de tva réduit à 5,5
afin d'acter que le tram est un produit
de première nécessité ainsi qu'un tarif
minimum pour les billets d'avion
nous proposons d'accompagner les ménages
modestes pour l'acquisition de véhicules
propres par la création d'un prêt à taux
zéro s'agissant des marchandises nous
tenons inscrire dans la loi l'objectif
de doubler la part modale du fret
ferroviaire et fluvial totalement oublié
pendant ces dernières années ensuite par
le verdissement de la flotte la tei cpe
l'écotaxe nous proposons respectivement
d'accompagner le secteur par des
dispositifs de sur amortissements ainsi
que plusieurs prêts à taux zéro de
conditionner toute augmentation de la
fiscalité à la disponibilité d'une offre
alternative et enfin que cette
contribution soit opérante si et
seulement si le secteur n'aurait pas
réduit significativement ses émissions
de gaz à effet de serre s'agissant des
mesures relatives au transport aérien
nous proposons que le secteur continue à
prendre par sa part pleine et entière
dans la décarbonation sans être
stigmatisé pour conclure nous
considérons nos propositions solides
parce que responsable solide parce que
techniquement possible
solide enfin parce que sur de leurs
portes et d'avenir ce message nous vous
proposons de vous y associer sur un
chemin de croissance à la fois porteurs
d'unités de justice de progrès
car comme le disait victor hugo le promu
le progrès n'est rien d'autre que la
révolution faite à l'amiable
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à la présidente
sophie primas président de la commission
des affaires économiques pour dix
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission du développement durable et
l'aménagement du territoire mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues c'est naturellement madame la
ministre avec beaucoup de sérieux
comme d'habitude et de sens des
responsabilités que nous avons examinés
ce projet de loi nous nous sommes
appuyés d'ailleurs à la commission des
affaires économiques sur l'expertisé et
la compétence reconnue de quatre
rapporteurs spécialistes de leur domaine
anne catherine loisier sur les sujets
concernant la consommation
l'alimentation l'agriculture et la forêt
dans le prolongement des travaux menés
sur la loi et galim dont elle est l un
des rapporteurs
dominique estrosi sassone évidemment sur
le logeait le le volet pardon logement
spécialiste de ces questions et qui a
notamment été rapporteur de la loi elle
daniel grémillet président du groupe
d'études énergie et rapporteur de la loi
énergie climat et enfin jean baptiste
blanc sur le volet artificialisation des
sols dans le prolongement d'un groupe de
travail qui l'a animé madame la mise
depuis le début de l'année je voudrais
ici dans un temps beaucoup trop limité
porter leurs voix afin de donner à cette
intervention une portée générale et je
veux rendre hommage à leur travail
passionné fait d'écouté de réflexion
avec leurs collègues des différentes
commissions et les administrateurs que
je sais d'où je veux madame la ministre
notre préoccupation constante a été
d'améliorer l'efficacité de ce texte
nous partageons en effet avec le
gouvernement l'idée qu'une transition
vers une économie plus sobre en carbone
n'est pas une option mais une nécessité
absolue
nous souhaitons une transition
écologique ambitieuse créateur créatrice
pardon de valeur et d'emplois
c'est une priorité identifiés par notre
commission depuis longtemps et de ce
point de vue l'opposition entre
l'économie et l'environnement est pour
nous un total contresens le dérèglement
climatique et la destruction de la
biodiversité sont des dangers majeurs
pour l'économie et à linverse la
transition écologique est un formidable
gisement de croissance et d'emploi pour
laquelle la france dispose de nombreux
atouts les chers collègues n'oublions
pas que la france se distingue d'ores et
déjà par de très faibles émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et dispose par
ailleurs de très nombreux et de très
performant acteurs économiques leaders
mondiaux en matière de croissance verte
c'est pourquoi nous avons la conviction
que cette transformation de notre
économie se fera grâce au dynamisme des
entreprises des agriculteurs de tous les
acteurs et grâce au sens des
responsabilités des consommateurs des
français nous souhaitons transition qui
se font sur les découvertes
scientifiques sur l'innovation sur
l'entrepreneuriat sur la liberté sur la
responsabilité individuelle
l'avenir est pour nous une croissance
verte et vertueuse or trop longtemps la
france a amélioré son empreinte carbone
en délocalisant ses émissions client
n'apportant massivement des biens
notamment industrielle et agricole mais
désindustrialisé la france ce n'est pas
des gars décarbonés la planète
c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons une
transition écologique qui soit
compatible avec la compétitivité des
entreprises françaises
avec notre souveraineté et avec notre
responsabilité morale dans le monde
de même dans le secteur agricole
veillons à ce que nos exigences
environnementales légitime ne
renchérisse pas le prix des denrées
alimentaires ne crée pas des conditions
de concurrence tellement déloyale
qu'elle favorise toujours plus les
importations en provenance de pays qui
ne respectent pas nos exigences
oui il y à une complémentarité entre
l'atteinte d'une économie plus
décarbonés et la recherche d'une plus
grande souveraineté économique
vous l'aurez compris notre commission a
cherché à travers l'examen de ce texte
un juste équilibre entre des
préoccupations environnementales et
économiques auxquels j'ajouterai
évidemment des préoccupations sociales
la crise des gilets jaunes nous a en
effet montré le risque
créer des laissés-pour-compte de la
transition écologique
nous avons eu à coeur à travers nos
amendements d'embarquer si vous me
permettez cette expression tous les
français dans cette 13 transition dans
tous les domaines voici les cosy les
convictions qui ont animé notre
commission par conséquent quel jugement
portez-vous sur ce texte
je dirais sobrement qu'il comporte des
dispositions de portée inégale il fixe
indéniablement des objectifs pertinents
et propose dispositions utiles d'autres
mesures selon nous relève en revanche
que davantage d'affichage que
d'efficacité et certains articles sans
portée juridique relève plus de l'effet
d'annoncé que de la loi enfin le texte
fait des impasses que nous avons cherché
à combler notamment dans le domaine de
l'énergie ou des forêts chère anne
catherine le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui issu des travaux de la
commission a donc été un autre sens
considérablement enrichi nous avons
adopté 200 amendements en séance
qu'avons nous chercher à faire le
premier objectif a été de réhausser
l'ambition du texte nous avons sous
l'impulsion de rapporteur quand cela
était possible et utile rapprocher
certaines échéances élargi certaines
cibles ou champ d'application de
certaines mesures je pense notamment
pierre denic à la rénovation énergétique
des logements à l'affichage
environnemental ou à la lutte contre la
déforestation importés nous avons
deuxièmement chercher à combler les
angles morts du projet de loi et nous a
semblé important du muscle et le volet
énergétique dans la mesure où la
décarbonation de notre économie est en
premier lieu celle de notre mix
énergétique
c'est pourquoi nous avons ajouté des
dispositions relatives à
l'hydroélectricité à l'hydrogène
renouvelables et bas carbone et au
nucléaire
de la même façon nous avons ouvert le
sujet de la connaissance de nos sous
sols dans le cadre de la réforme du code
minier alors d'une transition économique
inédite reposant sur le numérique
reposant sur les batteries électriques
il n'est pas pensable de ne pas
connaître la richesse de nos propres
sous sol est de seulement compter sur
l'exploitation des sous sols des pays en
voie de développement dans des
conditions d'exploitation
environnementales et sociales souvent
bien moins vertueuse c'est une question
de souveraineté mais je vous le dis
c'est aussi une question de morale
nous avons adopté troisièmement des
dispositions pour accompagner les
ménages les plus précaires et les
petites entreprises
dans cette transition la commission a
adopté des amendements qui tendent à
lutter contre la précarité énergétique
en améliorant l'accès aux aides en
facilitant la réalisation de travaux en
garantissant un reste à charge minimale
ou en rendant possible la gratuité des
accompagnateurs seashell les pouvoirs
publics doivent préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des plus modestes dans cette
transition
faute de quoi et cela a été déjà dit
nous aurons une opposition frontale à
tout changement
nous avons adopté quatrièmement des
amendements pour recalibrer certains
dispositifs
je pense par exemple à la liste des
produits à privilégier dans la
restauration collective qui aujourd'hui
est trop restrictive et nous l'avons
élargi par exemple aux produits locaux
et aux circuits courts
je pense aussi à l'adoption d'un plan
éco azote plus incitatif plus
opérationnelles que des taxes qui ont
comme défaut majeur d'encore une fois
mettre nos agriculteurs en situation de
concurrence déloyale au sein même de
l'europe et de taxer tous les
agriculteurs
même les bons élèves nous ne sommes pas
des adeptes de la punition collective
nous avons cinquièmement souhaité
simplifier les dispositifs proposés
chaque fois que c'était possible
c'est en effet paradoxal que cette
transition écologique se traduisent par
la multiplication des normes
réglementaires qui souvent voire
toujours freine les initiatives c'est en
ce sens que nous avons simplifié les
dispositions sur les ré emploi des
friches ou l'exploitation de la petite
et d'électricité hydro électricité
il faut veiller à ce que cette
transition ne se traduisent pas par une
immixion croissante dans notre quotidien
d'un dirigisme étatique et
technocratique qui nous veut du bien
malgré nous tout en bridant les
initiatives les plus vertueuses et les
plus innovantes
nous avons enfin souhaité remettre et
cela ne vous étonnera pas les
collectivités territoriales au centre de
cette transition
la transition environnementale ne doit
pas être le prétexte d'une
recentralisation
dans ce pays jacobin il faut
décentraliser certaines décisions à un
échelon de proximité qui est les leçons
de la responsabilité
c'est le cas notamment en matière de
lutte contre l'artificialisation des
sols
c'est le cas aussi en matière
d'urbanisme commercial au total mes
chers collègues nous considérons que ce
texte sort renforcé des travaux en
commissions malgré vos réserves madame
la ministre nous le trouvons plus
ambitieux plus opérationnels plus
lisible plus efficace plus pragmatiques
loin de nous opposer très loin de nous
opposer à la démarche du gouvernement et
de nos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale nous avons souhaité saisir
cette occasion pour consolider la
transition du pays vers une économie
plus sobre en carbone
en misant sur les dispositifs les plus
efficaces pour leur impact positif sur
le climat alors j'espère que ce que vous
nous indiquiez tout à l'heure
l'intelligence collective ira à madame
la ministre
jusqu'à la volonté commune d'une cmt
positive
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente on en est pas
encore à la cmp pour le moment la parole
et à monsieur michel laugier rapporteur
pour avis de la commission de la culture
de l'éducation de la communication
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente sophie primas
monsieur le président jean françois
longeot mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues le
secteur de l'éducation de la culture et
de la communication doit prendre toute
sa place dans la protection de notre
environnement
est-ce que ce projet de loi constitue le
texte fondateur qui était promis
malheureusement non le projet de loi
comprend une profusion de mesures mais
dans la réalité celle ci n'auront pas
d'effets réels faute de volonté c'est
pourquoi la commission de la culture
s'est efforcé de soumettre plusieurs
mesures intégrées dans le texte de
commission qui doit avoir un véritable
impact sur les comportements ont fuit
concerne l'éducation tout d'abord nous
avons constaté que les apports de ce
texte sont principalement symbolique
l'éducation développement durable est
présente depuis près de 45 ans à l'école
la première instruction relative au
développement durable date de 1977
plus récemment la circulaire de la
rentrée 2020 met notamment en oeuvre la
refonte des programmes de la maternelle
au lycée
pour y renforcer les enseignements
relatifs aux changements climatiques à
la biodiversité et au développement
durable
concernant la publicité dans les médias
le gouvernement n'a pas réussi à
concilier son ambition pour
l'environnement et le modèle économique
des média privé les recettes
publicitaires représentent 95% des
ressources des chaînes privées
toute restriction à dont des
conséquences immédiates sur la qualité
des programmes
l'interdiction des publicités pour les
énergies fossiles prévues par l'article
3 il représenterait qu'une perte de 0 1%
des recettes publicitaires des chaînes
et de 0 3% pour les radios on mesure le
caractère symbolique de cette
disposition
quant à l'autorégulation prévue par
l'article 5
elle ne fixe aucun véritable objectif ni
aucun délai on peut donc penser que ce
dispositif ne fera qu accompagner
l'évolution naturelle de la consommation
sans essayer de faire évoluer les
comportements
la cohésion de la culture a donc
considéré que ces dispositions étaient
insuffisantes et qu'il fallait aller
plus loin sans pour autant menacer le
modèle économique des média nos
commission de la culture et du vent
durable ont inscrit dans le texte la
création d'un code de bonne conduite
dédié à france télévision radio france
et france médias monde celui-ci
organisera d'ici le 1er janvier 2023
la disparition des communications
commerciales promouvant des produits
ayant un effet négatif sur
l'environnement
dès lors qu'il existe des produits
alternatifs qui ne qui n'ont pas
d'effets néfastes sur l'environnement
la publicité ne représente que 10% des
ressources de l'audiovisuel public
il ya donc pas de difficulté à lui
demander d'être exemplaire l'état est le
seul actionnaire de ces sociétés
il doit être cohérent et refusé qu'elles
se financent au détriment de
l'environnement
s'agissant des dispositions qui modifie
le régime de la piste extérieure à
savoir les articles 6 et 7
les commissions de la culture et
développement durable sont tombés
d'accord pour proposer une solution qui
offre aux maires davantage de pouvoir
tout en empêchant les inégalités se
creusent exagérément sur le territoire
en matière d'affichage la publicité
extérieure constitue un effet un
véritable enjeu
d'intérêt local est il donc justifié que
les élus locaux disposent de davantage
de responsabilités dans ce domaine
mais pour lutter correctement contre la
pollution visuelle il faut aussi veiller
à ce que les prescriptions minimales
s'applique sur tout le territoire et que
les élus des petites communes qui
n'auraient pas les moyens humains ou
techniques nécessaires pour exercer la
police de la publicité puis se
transférer cette compétence c'est
l'objet des règles et sûrs des articles
6 et 7 que nous vous proposons pour
finir je veux mentionner les
dispositions du projet de loi destiné à
faciliter la rénovation énergétique des
logements sur la proposition de la
commission de la culture et bien sûr un
accord avec la commission des affaires
économiques
le texte propose aujourd'hui un
équilibre permettant à notre pays de
mieux répondre à cet enjeu essentiel
tout en tenant compte des contraintes
propres aux différents types de bâti la
commission de la culture crois fermement
que le patrimoine et le développement
durable sont compatibles et qu'il faut
en accentuer la bonne articulation
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant madame
christine lagarde rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des finances pour cinq
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre la commission des finances a
étudié seulement huit articles puisque
le texte tel qu'il est arrivé au sénat
est un texte et nous l'avons déplorer
essentiellement programmatique et qui
donc à ce stade dans sa rédaction
actuelle entraîne finalement peu de
charges pour les finances publiques
et quand des charges sont à prévoir
malheureusement elles sont difficilement
évaluable un seul exemple l'article 61
bis qui vient à créer un shack
alimentation et suivant les échanges que
nous avons pu avoir avec nos différents
interlocuteurs
les coûts pourraient être très élevés au
regard du périmètre qui sera décidé et
cet article 61 bis est un exemple
parfait de ce qu'est ce texte puisque la
mise en oeuvre en fait de cette
disposition doit s'accompagner du dépôt
de deux rapports donc on voit bien ici
ce qu'est ce texte beaucoup de grandes
idées mais avec une réalisation concrète
qui se fera sur le long terme
ce que nous avons aussi déplorer c'est
finalement une étude d'impact qui est
souvent défaillante
nous avons notamment aux déploré que les
conséquences socio économiques ne soient
pas suffisamment appréhender un seul
exemple nous avons pu lire qui n'est pas
un certain que cette mesure puisse avoir
des effets sur le secteur de
l'automobile
quand on porte des différentes mesures
qui concerne les interdictions de
circulation des poids lourds ou des
véhicules pour autant pour les secteurs
que la commission des finances a eu à
regarder
400000 emplois dans le secteur de la
construction automobile 400000 emplois
dans le secteur du transport routier de
marchandises trois cent vingt mille
emplois dans le domaine de l'aviation
civile
on voit bien que ce texte engage notre
économie sur le long terme
de même l'absence d'étude d'impact
fouillé fait que les conséquences
techniques des différentes dispositions
ont été mal ou peu appréhendé par
exemple interdire la circulation des
trains et des camions à moteur thermique
ne peut se faire que si jamais nous
avons une offre alternative
or aujourd'hui pour tous les camions
d'un poids en charge supérieur à 3,5
tonnes
il n'existe pas d'offre suffisante il
n'existe pas non plus et 7
rennes n'est pas équivalente elle n'est
pas équivalent puisqu'elle va entraîner
des transferts dans le plan de transport
puisqu'il va être nécessaire de sa vie
taille et plus régulièrement que si les
bandes ne sont pas là il faudra
construire le plan en fonction des
endroits où on pourra soit vie taille et
elle n'est pas équivalent puisque les
capacités d'emport vont être réduites
avec de l'hydrogène ou un moteur
électrique qui va prendre du volume sur
le volume utile pour charger des
marchandises et comme je le disais elle
n'est pas équivalente puisque
aujourd'hui la question de
l'avitaillement est un point crucial et
qui fait défaut nous avons au 1er mai
uniquement 38000 points de recharge pour
les véhicules à hydrogène ou les
véhicules électriques
alors même que l'ambition de la france
était d'avoir cent mille points au 1er
janvier 2022 nous en sommes donc très
loin c'est les raisons pour lesquelles
avec donc mes collègues et notamment
philippe tabarot nous avons choisi
d'accompagner la transition alors
effectivement vous allez me dire qu'un
certain nombre de dispositifs existent
pour en temps si j'en crois encore un
article publié ce jour dans un grand
journal national
les citoyens eux ont le sentiment d'être
un peu les laissés-pour-compte surtout
lorsqu'ils vont avoir besoin de rentrer
dans une zone à faible émission alors
certes vous allez me dire le plan de
relance 1,5 milliard pour accompagner
des avions vers vous allez me dire des
bonus pour les camions mais nous sommes
quand même très loin du compte
aujourd'hui un camion à hydrogène à un
coût complet d'utilisation qui est deux
à trois fois plus élevé que n'importe
quelle motorisation les seuls
motorisations alternatives pour des
camions qui soit à peu près équilibrés
sur la durée de vie à un moteur
thermique sont celles au gazole ou par
mon bioéthanol donc nous y sommes loin
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons choisi d'accompagner cette
transition et philippe tada tabarot a
donné déjà un certain nombre des mesures
notamment compléter les prêts à taux
zéro prolonger le dispositif de sur
amortissements mettre en place une
trajectoire de diminution de
l'exonération partielle de thé icpe
uniquement si des moyens de substitution
sont bien mis en place c'est à dire à la
fois une offre de camions et en même
temps un nombre de points
d'avitaillement suffisant pour qu'il
soit possible de
livrer des marchandises en tout point du
territoire national et pas uniquement le
long des axes autoroutiers dans le
domaine agricole nous avons décidé de
mettre en place un plan éco azote qui
aidera nos agriculteurs à la transition
et le dernier point sur lesquelles la
commission des finances s'est prononcée
est celui d'un besoin impératif de
discuter avec nos partenaires européens
sur tout un tas de ces sujets qui
entraîne des besoins de convergence de
notre fiscalité
nous ne pouvons pas agir seul par
exemple dans le domaine de la fiscalité
sur les carburants aujourd'hui en france
nous sommes au dessus de la moyenne
européenne
et parmi les pays qui nous entourent
seule l'allemagne à une fiscalité plus
désavantagés aussi je peux le dire comme
ça pour les transporteurs donc vous
comprenez bien qu'ils peuvent aller ceux
qui sont près de la frontière pour aller
acheter l'essence de l'autre côté et ça
ne les empêchera pas de rouler sur le
territoire national ces chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur
stéphane le rudulier rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des lois pour cinq
minutes
[Applaudissements]
je
bien monsieur le président madame la
ministre madame la présidente monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
la commission des lois s'est saisi pour
une trentaine de dispositions des
articles de ce projet de loin sur les
218 que comporte le projet initialement
dans des domaines assez variés que sont
la protection judiciaire de
l'environnement
la commande publique la lutte contre
l'orpaillage en guyane des mesures sur
les transports la luttre contre
l'artificialisation des sols et voyez
vous madame amis je ne partage pas votre
enthousiasme sur ce texte car quand on y
regarde de près c'est un texte d'une
facture juridiquement décevante qui
comporte et ça a été dit de manière
répétée des dispositions normatives ou
relativement peu aboutis et j'en veux
pour preuve les dispositions pénales
destiné à réprimer plus sévèrement des
atteintes graves aux à l'environnement
et durable nous sommes attachés à
réécrire l'article 68 afin de tenir
compte des remarques du conseil d'état
on essaie la rédaction initiale figurant
dans le projet de loi semblait fragile
au regard des principes constitutionnels
et d'ailleurs la commission
développement durable avec madame la
rapporteure martha de cidre ac est allé
beaucoup plus loin que la commission des
lois en trouvant également un juste
équilibre puisqu'elle a fait évoluer à
la fois le quantum des peines et le
seuil retenu pour définir la teinte
durable à l'environnement
deuxième point de divergence sur le
terme écocide quand on regarde la
littérature juridique on s'aperçoit très
vite que le terme écocide est un crime
qui pourrait d'ailleurs être reconnus à
l'échelle du droit international
utiliser ce terme pour désigner un délit
dans notre droit interne paraît quelque
peu inapproprié
la commission des lois également veiller
à mieux encadrer l'utilisation des
drones pour les agents de contrôle
chargé de veiller au respect des normes
environnementales
à la lumière de ses travaux sur la ppl
sécurité globale et plus récemment sur
les la décision du conseil
constitutionnel
quelques mots sur le volet transport
pour vous dire que la perspective de la
création d'une écotaxe régional a
suscité un débat assez intense et riche
ça notre commission nous avions
initialement proposé de supprimer
purement et simplement cette mesure
tout simplement pour la réétudier et l'a
renvoyé au débat du futur projet de loi
3ds
parce que voyez vous on avoue trouver
quelque peu inconvenant de bâtir un
dispositif fiscal régional sur une
domanialité qui n'était pas encore
transféré aux régions
néanmoins la rédaction retenue par la
commission du développement durable sur
proposition de philippe tabarot répond à
notre prix préoccupations puisqu'elle
conditionne l'éventuelle création de
cette taxe aux efforts réalisés pour le
secteur routier de marchandises à
l'horizon 2028
et puis un dernier point sur
l'artificialisation des sols
si notre commission adhère à l'objectif
d'une réduction du rythme de
l'artificialisation des sols
il ne faudrait pas néanmoins contraindre
excessivement les collectivités
territoriales les communes qui sont je
pense les mieux à même de décliner
localement les objectifs définis à
l'échelon national
ainsi
s'il est légitime que l'estrade est fixe
les grandes orientations
il est tout aussi légitime que les
collectivités territoriales conserve
selon nous la souplesse pour leur mise
en oeuvre
les élus locaux à travers les organes
délibérants se doivent de concilier
production de la vie propre tradition
l'environnement pardon avec des
objectifs de construction de logements
et de développement économique et social
au plus près des spécificités de chaque
territoire et sous l'oeil avisé de leurs
électeurs voilà mes chers collègues très
succinctement les principales
conclusions de la commission des lois
qui a souhaité vous l'aurez compris
garantir l'efficacité du travail tout en
le consolidant sur un plan juridique et
en veillant à ce que la cohérence avec
les principes constitutionnels et notre
droit pénal soit garanti merci chers
collègues dans la discussion générale
nous passerons aux orateurs des groupes
paix nous commençons par le président
claude malhuret pour le groupe les
indépendants pour six minutes
madame la ministre la loi que vous nous
présentez à une méthode qui nous
interroge un contenu qui ne mérite ni
excès d'honneur de ses thuriféraires ni
surtout l' excès d'indignité des
décibels au crac de la deep ecology qui
protège le samedi dans des cortèges
assez maigrelet et enfin un contexte la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
que je l'espère personne ici ne conteste
la méthode est celle de la convention
citoyenne depuis les îles et jaune se
multiplient les suggestions d'objets
volants non identifiés sorte d'hybride
entre une pseudo démocratie directe et
un panel pour instituts de sondage tel
que le référendum d'initiative populaire
où les convention citoyenne qui pose
question à la démocratie représentative
le parlement aura le dernier mot nous
dites vous peut-être mais sous la
pression médiatique d'une convention à
la légitimité non définie aux
participants désigné par la providence
et dont il a fallu faire ce site une
mise à niveau préalable si bien que les
propositions en fait dépendu de quelques
animateurs chevronnés choisi eux sans
tirage au sort ces garde fous en hélas
vite cédé le plus activistes de ces
pygmalion ne cessant désormais de mordre
la main qui lui a offert sa soudaine
notoriété dans un exercice de dépit
amoureux qui a beaucoup moins à voir
avec le réchauffement climatique avec
son propre échauffement nouvelles formes
de la démocratie nous dites vous
je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle soit plus
vertueuses que l'ancien j'en viens au
contenu de la loi et sur ce point je
serai plus nuancé un projet qui met dans
la rue les quelques milliers de
décroissante east collapse aux log et à
dist qui a fait l'objet l'assemblée
nationale d'une motion de rejet de la
france soumise à bolivar un projet
conspué par une coalition improvisé des
ong les plus radicales ne peut être
entièrement mauvais la convention
citoyenne elle à laquelle vous proclamez
votre amour vous a donné une note de 3
points 3 sur 10 sont animateurs et
chauffée crie partout que vous n'avez
repris au resco référence que moins d'un
tiers de ses propositions
je veux pour ma part y voir le signe de
votre lucidité
car cette convention a accouché de trois
sortes de mesures des mesures techniques
parfois déjà entreprises comme la
rénovation des logements l'économie
circulaire la décarbonation des
transports qui vont dans le bon sens
ensuite des solutions à la française qui
proclament des bons sentiments et
rendent les loi bavarde
la modification de la constitution par
exemple qui n'ajoute est rien et
préparer des contentieux 'sinon bras et
enfin un catalogue de contraintes fonds
de commerce des décroissants vous avez
choisi les mesures qui vous paraissaient
les plus pertinentes et surtout les
moins chimérique
le sénat a donc choisi de les étudier
façon sérieuse et constructive en
conciliant développement durable et
justice sociale
en privilégiant une écologie
décentralisée qu'ils n'aggravent pas les
factures les fractures économique
sociale ou territoriale mais cherche à
les réparer et enfin en trente ans de
maîtriser l'explosion normative qui
s'annonce et qui angoissent déjà chef
d'entreprise agriculteurs artisans
commerçants et beaucoup d'élus il me
reste à parler du contexte marqué par
l'opposition des partisans de la
croissance verte et de ceux de la
décroissance l'écologie est un champ de
bataille déclarait à l'assemblée matile
de panneaux de la france insoumise je
suis d'accord avec elle sur ce point
même si nous en tirerons des conclusions
opposées faire de la décroissance un
modèle est inapplicable économiquement
et politiquement est donc vouée à
l'échec
quel sens peut avoir la décroissance
pour le milliard d'habitants des tiers
et quart monde qui vivent avec moins de
2 euros par jour
quel sens pour les 2 autres milliards
qui vivent de lopins de terre épuisé de
petits boulots de travail au noir
quel sens même chez nous pour les
ménages à petits budgets mal-logés
exposés au chômage au surendettement à
l'insécurité
la décroissance n'est pas que le mot
d'ordre des verts énième avatar de la
haine du libéralisme c'est aussi l'opium
des bobos comme nous l'ont prouvé avec
éclat en une de monde il ya quelques
mois dans une tribune aussi subversif
que lee fromage à tartiner une brochette
de stars kérosène au bilan carbone le
plus élevé de la planète qui n'imagine
pas une seconde se l'appliquer à
eux-mêmes et qui si elle devait être
adoptée ne contribuerait au
développement durable que des
ronds-points réorienter la croissance
vers un mode de vie
plus respectueux de la terre et des
hommes c'est l'extraordinaire et
passionnant défis de notre génération
malheureusement la conçurent n'a pas
répondu aux questions essentielles
comment parvenir à énergie à une énergie
décarbonée si l'on se prive du nucléaire
comment cesser d'entraver les nouvelles
techniques de génomique agricoles
nécessaires pour résoudre l'impossible
équation des pesticides et préserver le
climat alors même que ces techniques ont
valu le prix nobel à une française en
comment faire payer les émissions de
carbone aux frontières et bientôt
l'europe a largement raté la grande
révolution du numérique
la prochaine et celle des industries de
la transition écologique
c'est là qu'est l'enjeu majeur du plan
de relance posco vie si nous manquons
l'occasion de ces milliards d'euros pour
investir dans cette révolution qui
s'appelle hydrogène vers stockage
électrique ciment acier et engrais zéro
carbone fusion nucléaire géothermie
nouvelles techniques génomiques agricole
et tout ce que les milliers d'étudiants
de 20 ans sont en train d'étudier sans
que nous sachions encore si nous
choisissons de sombrer dans l'écologie
du gentil avec les arbres méchant avec
les hommes alors nous aurons échoué deux
fois la première parce que nous serons
définitivement relégué derrière les
états unis et la chine
la seconde bien plus grave parce qu'il
sera trop tard pour répondre à l'urgence
climatique
quand vous avez pris le train dans la
mauvaise direction rien ne sert de
courir en sens contraire dans le couloir
voici le défi qui vous attend madame la
ministre qui attend tous les
gouvernements à venir et qui nous attend
tous merci
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur ronan dantec pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
pour six minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues il y a deux mois
le vignoble français étaient frappées
par le gel avec destruction de la
majorité des bourgeons mais si ce coup
de froid assez fréquent en avril a été
aussi catastrophique
c'est d'abord parce qu'il l'avait fait
particulièrement chaud au mois de mars
et que les bourgeons était anormalement
avancé de plus si le vignoble eux le
vignoble est aujourd'hui aussi
économiquement fragilisé notamment dans
mon département de loire atlantique
c'est aussi du fait de la sécheresse de
l'été dernier qui dans les trois
dernières semaines avant les vendanges
avaient déjà durement affectées et décès
chez les grands cet exemple concret
parmi tant d'autres témoignent de
l'impact réel du réchauffement
climatique
il n'ya plus débat sur le fait établi
par consensus scientifique de la
responsabilité humaine dans cette
situation nous avons ainsi enregistré
une augmentation des températures de 1,1
degré depuis les temps prix industriels
et cette hausse s'accélère dans un monde
qui n'a jamais autant brûler de charbon
ou de pétrole et donc émis autant de co2
et autres gaz à effet de serre plus à
1,1 degré cela suffit pour menacer
l'activité l'avenir de toute l'activité
viticole française au point de voir de
grandes maisons de champagne acheter des
terres en écosse mais c'est aussi à
l'échelle mondiale une sécheresse
terrible en californie et des
températures records enregistrées au
mexique ou en iran dira t'on jamais
assez comme l'expliqué très bien al gore
dans ses conférences
quand dans les soubassements de la crise
syrienne
il y à ces sécheresses à répétition qui
ont chassé les paysans de leurs terres
et contribuer à la déstabilisation du
pays
la crise climatique rentre toujours en
résonance avec d'autres crises et
tension comme on le voit aussi par
exemple avec boko haram autour du
chat et nous ne sommes qu'à 1,1 degré
l'horizon de la neutralité carbone en
2050 ne peut suffire
tout se joue dans les prochaines années
si nous ne réduisons pas rapidement nos
émissions mondiales de l'ordre de 50%
d'ici 2030 alors nous vivrons au 21e
siècle avec des températures de plus 3
+4° qui apparaissent totalement
incompatible avec l'autonomie
alimentaire mondial le maintien de
centaines de millions d'habitants de
cette planète sur leurs territoires
ancestraux
ce n'est pas être catastrophique mais
lucide de rappeler que sans une réponse
résolu et rapide de la communauté
mondiale notre monde sera demain du fait
du réchauffement climatique en situation
d'affrontement multiples pour ne pas
dire généralisé face à ce risque connu
et admis comme l'a encore réaffirmé le
g7 ce week-end il faut donc une réponse
mondiale
elle est coordonnée aujourd'hui dans le
complexe et fragile accord de paris qui
fut un vrai succès de la diplomatie
française l'accord de paris repose sur
un principe simple chacun doit faire sa
part et à la suite de l'échec de la
négociation de copenhague en 2019 j'y
étais chacun s'engage atteint l'objectif
qu'il s'est volontairement fixé les
états seront ainsi tous les cinq ans
pour vérifier qu'ils ont atteint
l'objectif précédent et proposé des
engagements plus ambitieux ainsi par
cycle de cinq ans nous avançons vers
l'objectif que s'est fixé le monde à
paris en 2015 stabiliser l'augmentation
sous les deux degrés au plus près du 1,5
nous sommes donc réunis au sénat pour
répondre à cette question finalement
très simple la france s'organise-t-elle
pour décliner et crédibiliser le nouvel
objectif européen de -55% qui sera
présenté à la cote de glasgow et câlins
soutenue dans les sommets européens
et c'est bien là que le bât blesse la
réponse est non
les différentes estimations qui ont été
faites par ceux sur ce projet loi
notamment par le haut conseil au climat
ou par le boston liste études montrent
que les mesures que vous proposez madame
la ministre nous permettront d'atteindre
que - 30 - 35 % de réduction de gaz à
effet de serre en 2030
bien loin de l'objectif européen nous
avons donc quinze jours
pour changer en profondeur ce projet de
loi et montrer au monde que la france
est aujourd'hui un pays moteur de
l'accord de paris le groupe écologiste a
tracé la voie avec sa vraie loi climat
qui montre que la france peut y arriver
- 55 % en 2030 par des mesures
finalement assez simple d'obligations de
rénovation thermique de sortie accélérée
de la mobilité thermique fossiles de
réduction drastique de l'utilisation
d'engrais azotés et d'augmentation de
nos puits de carbone en lien avec la
reconquête de la biodiversité
surtout nous défendons une vision de cet
effort collectif qu'ils en fassent aussi
un outil de solidarité et de
redistribution
c'est la clé de la nécessaire adhésion
collective à cette transition
nos deux semaines de débats seront donc
l'occasion de discuter de ses mesures
ambitieuses mais on rien inaccessible
pour cette vraie loi climat nous sommes
évidemment inspiré de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat c'est 150
citoyens tirés au sort que votre
gouvernement avait mandaté pour définir
des mesures trouver des consensus des
points d' équilibre de la société
française et permettent d'atteindre
c'était l'objectif de l'époque - 40 % en
2030 ce processus démocratique novateur
fait pour justement créer des consensus
dans des adhésions dans la société avait
donc suscité beaucoup d'intérêt et aussi
quelques craintes au sénat nous venons
de le réentendre
malheureusement vous n'en avez pas tenu
la promesse une forme de parjure disons
le mot par rapport à l'engagement du
président de la république de reprendre
sans filtre les propositions de ce
travail inédit il en reste donc un
affaiblissement dangereux de la parole
politique
hélas le sentiment que la france
renâclent devant l'effort à accomplir
pour assumer sa part de la
responsabilité mondiale
nous avons donc quinze jours je le redis
pour montrer notre sens des
responsabilités
montrer aux grands émetteurs mondiaux à
la chine aux états unis alain que la
france fait sa part et que nous sommes
de ce fait en droit de réclamer
notamment dans le cadre d'échangés
codéine mondiaux réguler qu'ils assument
aussi leur part de l'effort c'est tout
l'enjeu de ce texte
le groupe écologiste sera donc
totalement mobilisé pour que sort du
sénat un projet de loi enfin à la
hauteur de l'enjeu qui est tout
simplement l'avenir même
de l'humanité merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur
frédéric marchand pour le beau-père des
pays pour quatre minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le projet de loi
dont nous entamons l'examen aujourd'hui
il nous adresse un double défi celui de
conjuguer démocratie participative et
démocratie représentative d'une part
celui d' accélérer la transition
écologique d'autre part j'ai encore
comme beaucoup présent l'esprit les
propos du président de la république
emmanuel macron en 2017
le changement climatique est l'un des
plus grands défis de notre temps et si
nous ne faisons rien aux enfants vont
connaître un monde de migration de
guerre et de pénurie peu importe où nous
vivons nous partageons la même
responsabilité beaucoup de chemin a été
parcouru depuis cette date grâce à la
politique volontariste de la france est
le dernier rapport de l'institut à force
ils témoignent de ce chemin de cette
volonté relever le défi de la transition
écologique engagent notre responsabilité
celle d'additionner les volontés surtout
nos territoires pas d'exclure ni de
diviser le mouvement des gilet jaune
nous a d'ailleurs rappelé à quel point
l'acceptation de la transition par la
population était crucial et n'allait pas
de soi
permettez moi ce stade de saluer
l'extraordinaire travail mené par les
rapporteurs travail menée à marche
forcée mais qui s'est fait dans un
travail d'exigence d'ouverture et
d'écouté et non cette loi ce n'est pas
une oie des petits pas comme certains la
caricature et les faits sont têtus
cette loi c'est une contribution engagé
et engageant tout respect des accords de
paris 2015 à l'agenda 2030 des eaux
d'été au pacte vert pour l'europe
quand ce sont 200 milliards d'euros qui
sont actionnés par an de commande
publique pour la transition écologique
ce n'est pas un messi pas quand et
planifier la rénovation de plus de 4
millions de logements qui sont des
passoires thermiques
ce n'est pas un jeune type santé décidé
la réduction par deux du rythme
d'artificialisation des sols pour
l'ensemble du pays ce n'est pas un petit
pas dans le verdissement de l'ensemble
des flottes de véhicules de l'état des
collectivités des entreprises et
accélérer ce n'est pas un dit pas quand
est adoptée la fin des lignes aériennes
au profit du train dans le pays qui est
le leader mondial de l'aéronautique
ce n'est pas un petit pas quand enfin
ils généralisent et l'obligation de 50 %
de produits durables dans des produits
bio aux 300 millions de repas annuel de
la restauration collective privé ce
n'est pas un petit à ce sont des pas de
géant pour une transformation écologique
profonde de notre société
le travail mené par le rapporteur a bien
évidemment fait bouger les lignes du
texte et nous appartiendra dans le cadre
de notre débat de porter propositions
l'argument visant à corriger certains
points contraire à l'ambition initiale
du texte et en rehausser d'autres je
pense ici plus particulièrement au titre
1 3 et 5 sur des sujets comme
l'information du consommateur les
prolongements de la loi avec le
transport ferroviaire et le sujet des
mobilités douces ou bien encore les
sujets d'alimentation durable véritables
enjeux des années à venir
tout comme l'est celui du logement et
notamment l'épineuse question de la
rénovation du bâti ancien mes chers
collègues la transformation écologique
elle passera avant tout par un
changement des comportements
assumons collectivement le fait de
privilégier l'information des
consommateurs et les incitations plutôt
que les interdictions arbitraires
souvent teintées d'anticapitalisme
primaire méfions-nous le ces nouveaux
idéologues qui appelle au grand
dérangement comme d'autres avant eux à
de grands bonds en avant ils mènent à
l'autoritarisme la misère collective ce
n'est pas notre conception de l'écologie
ce n'est pas ma conception d'écologie
l'écologie partager c'est celle qui tend
vers l'idéal mais c'est celle qui
comprendre et l
chers collègues il y à bien un chemin
entre ceux pour qui aucune mesure ne
sera jamais satisfaisante et ceux qui
considèrent qu'il ne faudrait jamais
rien changé entre une écologie de
l'injonction permanente devenue une
véritable rente politique et un
immobilisme coupable face à l'impératif
climatique
cette voie centrale de bon sens pour une
écologie de terrain et du quotidien
c'est celle tracée par la majorité
une écologie qui investit massivement
dans le progrès technique et
d'innovation une écologie des solutions
concrètes de l'incitation et de
l'accompagnement une écologie de
l'éducation et de l'adhésion de la
population
c'est tout le sens de la politique
connaît depuis 2010 est du plan de
relance vers 200 milliards d'euros et de
ce projet de loi qui maillent résilience
ce texte il nous aidera à tenir nos
engagements climatiques ils
contribueront à amplifier la
transformation écologique de la société
et orienter notre économie valeur
décarbonation économie et écologie sont
compatibles nous ne cessons devra leurs
conjugaisons
alors je ne doute pas qu aux débats
permettront d'aller plus loin plus haut
plus fort pour une transition écologique
au service de toutes et tous merci chers
collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur jean
pierre corbisez du groupe rds ce pour
sept minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mesdames messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues nous y sommes nous
apprêtons à engager les débats sur l'une
des lois a annoncé comme l'une des
réformes phares du quinquennat ou moins
sur ce sujet le présent des pluies qui
aura tenu son engagement d'inscrire à
l'ordre du jour de notre haute assemblée
alors s'agit-il d'une grande loi comme
on nous a été présenté rien n'est moins
sûr mais mon groupe
comme d'autres madame la ministre sera
là pour la faire grandir
six titres 69 articles lors de son dépôt
x trop après le passage à l'assemblée
nationale et en commission cela reflète
l'ampleur du chantier qui nous sépare de
nos objectifs en matière de climat une
réelle ambition affichée par le
gouvernement et courageusement porté par
vous madame la ministre
mais la quantité la quantité fort
at-elle la qualité
notre ambition pour ce texte n'est
visiblement pas la même que celle
affichée par le gouvernement
nous aurions collectivement souhaitait
aller beaucoup plus loin malheureusement
le poids des lobbys est encore très
présent trop sans doute
je pense d'ailleurs à ceux qui
souhaitaient la suppression des moulins
mais en tout cas au sein de notre
commission nous avons su résister et sur
tous les modes de pensée n'ont pas
encore opéré leur mutation
ce thème nous devons réaliser un virage
à 180 degrés et placé l'environnement et
sa préservation
au coeur de toutes nos actions je dirais
qu'en la matière la révolution
intellectuelle à opérer est du même
ordre que celles concernant la mise en
place du revenu universel
nous devons mettre l'intégralité des
secteurs d'activités au service de
l'environnement
je pense à l'énergie aux transports et
plus généralement à l'économie à la
finance en faire la priorité et non l
inverse
alors oui il ya des impacts oui il ya
des résistances
oui il ya des enjeux économiques et
sociaux willy à des adaptations complexe
mais c'est un mal nécessaire une dette
que nous détenons envers les générations
futures
surtout le rôle de l'état est le nôtre
en tant que parlementaire et de créer
les conditions nécessaires à cette
transition avec des mesures incitatives
à calendrier progressif et réaliste de
la pédagogie de l'écouté et de la
concertation
en résumé un verre une véritable feuille
de route est avant tout de la clarté et
de la visible
et pour les acteurs bien que danser
multipolaire ce projet de loi n'en
relève pas moins malgré tout une forme
de saupoudrage des habits d'une
véritable ligne directrice c'est une des
raisons qui m'a poussé à 5 ainsi que
d'autres collègues de la commission
d'aménagement du territoire a déposé un
amendement de principe visant à engager
résolument d'autres pays dans le respect
des objectifs européens de réduction des
émissions de nos gaz à effet de faire un
symbole fort dans la perspective de la
présidence française à venir une france
qu'il doit être le moteur de la
transition écologique de l'europe comme
elle l'a été pour de nombreuses autres
politiques européennes comme s'y est
engagé le président de la république
nous savons que nous sommes loin et que
les lois adoptées jusqu'à présent mais
bien trop pas d'atteindre les 40 % de
réduction à l'horizon 2030
que dire alors du réhaussement de cette
ambition à 55 % au niveau européen
d'ailleurs frappant d'observer la
profusion des amendements que nous avons
reçus les uns les autres
destinée à compliquer les infléchir
enfourcher les dispositions adoptées au
travers des lourds et lents et galim âge
etc ou encore biodiversité s'agit donc
bien d'une loi de correction qui reprend
le sens d'amendements déposés au
parlement par le passé par certains
d'entre nous pour le reste il est
impossible évidemment d'entrer dans le
détail de chaque article
tant qu'ils sont nombreux et disparates
mais quelques points d'accroché tout de
même je débuterai par un sujet qui me
tient par dion hackers rapporte l'élu
issus du bassin minier du pas-de-calais
l'exploitation minière a durement
touchés et touche encore de nombreuses
communes qu'il s'agisse de la
fragilisation de la pollution des sols
la remontée des ans la gestion des
friches industrielles ou encore des
conséquences sociales et sanitaires
pesant sur ses habitants n'ayons pas
peur des mots c'est encore un véritable
traumatisme
le prix payé par les régions minières
justifie amplement que la réforme du
code minier annoncée est promise donne
lieu à un véritable débat parlementaire
un débat dans lequel le sénat pourra
pleinement défendre les intérêts des
collectivités concernées
aussi je réitère ma proposition formulée
en commission d'une suppression de
l'article 21 habilitant le gouvernement
a procédé en matière par ordonnance même
si le parlement a pleinement participé à
inscrire en
sur une partie des habilitations
mainenant n'oublions pas le passé tu as
un sujet proche
je souhaite que soit d'apporter une
attention particulière la présentation
lors de nos débats en séance
des articles de la proposition de loi
notre collègue gisèle jourda et maryse
carrère relatives à la gestion des sols
pollués les dispositions fondamentales
qui ont fait l'objet d'un travail d'une
concertation approfondie dans le cadre
de la commission d' enquête qui a rendu
son rapport en septembre dernier
en second lieu on peut regretter que le
texte fasse l'impasse sur cette un
secteur pourtant sensible pour
l'environnement comme le numérique le
transport ferroviaire à caen l'hydrogène
dans le transport ferroviaire
il ya va de même de la question des
aspects sociaux de la transition
écologique principalement regard de
notre principe de républicain d'égalité
les bienfaits de la transition
écologique doivent pouvoir être
accessible à tous à titre personnel je
vais aussi m'exprimer sur mon
interrogation quant à l'application
parfois très strictes et dispositif de
l'article 45 légitime de souhaiter de ne
pas polluer le débat par les amas de
cavaliers mais cette lecture de
l'article 45 a conduit à l'hoggy
l'irrecevabilité de chacun amendement
pourtant en cohérence avec l'objectif de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre que
poursuit le texte
on les remettra lors de l'examen de la
loi de 3ds les amendements qui répondait
par ailleurs au principe que gênant
siens à l'introduction de mon propos
consistant à accompagner au mieux les
acteurs impactés par des évolutions
législatives
certes justifiée par nos ambitions
environnementales mais parfois
difficilement applicable voie intenable
pour le secteur concerné nos commissions
se sont malgré tout est forcé de réussir
le texte avec la lutte contre
l'écoblanchiment ans le verdissement de
la commande publique ou du parc de poids
lourds la protection des écosystèmes ou
encore la lutte contre la déforestation
l'autre groupe n'a pas été en reste en
proposant moins de pas moins de 145
amendements j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
saluer le travail effectué par notre
charge d'une mission
je pense que ça a été la même chose dans
d'autres groupes mais la main ministre
les enjeux sont considérables et ce
projet de loi n'y suffira pas c'est
entendu mais les choses évoluent mais
continueront à évoluer ici et on se doit
de souligner les initiatives vertueuse
prises par de nombreuses collectivités
filières industrielles ou entreprises
les projets autour des circuits courts
de l'économie circulaire ou encore de la
conception sans qu'on s'en d'origine
naturelle des produits ménagers ou
cosmétiques fleurissent vont donc être
résolument optimiste et en tant que
parlementaire si nous devons être des
vigiles nous devons aussi être des
précurseurs et donner un élan une
direction et deux semaines de débats qui
s'ouvrent à nous sont déterminantes et
je gage que nous aurons tous à coeur
avec vous mener nos ministres
d'améliorer encore ce texte pour en
gagner notre pays sur la voie est
nécessaire et urgente la transition
écologique jour merci merci cher que
leïla poleman à madame marie-claude
varaillas ce pour le groupe crc eux pour
sept minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues alors que la
création de la convention citoyenne
avait suscité une certaine forme d'
enthousiasme le projet de loi qui nous
est soumis après de multiples
renoncement brise les promesses et ne
crée pas les conditions de répondre à la
feuille de route initiale celle de
baisser les émissions de 40% à l'horizon
et ce dans un esprit de justice sociale
je commencerai cette intervention par
quelques remarques de fond de forme
pardon vous le savez notre groupe est
particulièrement attentif au
renforcement de l'irruption démocratique
dans ce cadre la convention citoyenne
représente un outil utile
malheureusement des voiliers et
instrumentalisé par le pouvoir en place
au travers des manoeuvres dilatoires et
électoralistes par ailleurs la procédure
parlementaire qui en découlent nous
semble nous semble soulever un certain
nombre d'interrogations
en effet cette innovation démocratique
ne peut se traduire par une forme de
musellement du parlement cantonné au
rôle de simples chambres
d'enregistrement de mesures définies
ailleurs soit objet de veto ou de
réécriture présidentielle soit d'une
reprise sans filtre il est d'ailleurs
regrettable de voir dans ce projet de
loi une multitude d'habilitation à
légiférer par voie d'ordonnancé qui
confirme une forme de dessaisissement
une fois de plus du parlement un mot ici
sur les conditions d'examen par nos
commissions les travaux malheureusement
dû être mené au pas de charge ce que
nous avons regretté la création de la
convention citoyenne et puisse donc pas
le besoin de renouvellement des
pratiques démocratiques de rééquilibrage
des pouvoirs
tout comme de l'exigence de
démocratisation du dialogue social loin
s'en faut
sur le fond ce projet de loi est en
recul par rapport aux propositions des
150 citoyens générant il faut bien le
dire frustration et déception
c'est ainsi qu' aucune des propositions
de la loi climat et résilience n'a
d'ailleurs obtenu la moyenne auprès des
conventionnels leur nom était très
sévère et ça a été dit 3 sur 10 les
associations sont également critiques
sur ce projet de loi tout comme
le céser le haut conseil pour le piment
ou encore le cnpe
tous déplorent que les nombreuses
mesures du projet de loi reste souvent
limité différé ou soumises à des
conditions telles que leur mise en
oeuvre
en termes rapprochée est incertaine il
regrette l'absence de changement de
logiciel et le manque de moyens il
dénonce enfin des délais manifestement
incompatible avec le rythme attendu de
l'action contre le changement climatique
et le rattrapage du retard pris par la
france dans l'atteinte de ses budgets
carbone
au fond on a le sentiment d'une liste à
la prévert de mesures est parfois
dénuées de cohérence entre elles déjà
traités dans les différents projets de
loi soumis à notre assemblée parfois
même il ya très peu de temps pour être
plus précis nous regrettons notamment
que le projet de loi fasse l'impasse sur
des propositions importantes même si je
souligne ici les apports fait en
commission par le sénat nous y
reviendrons dans le débat nous
continuons ainsi de regretter que ce
projet de loi ne prévoit toujours pas
l'obligation de rénovation globale des
logements de l'ensemble des logements qu
ils n'interdisent pas les passoires
thermiques en prévoyant les sanctions
adéquates mais seulement leur mise en
location si le texte pose en un principe
général d'interdiction de nouveaux
centres commerciaux de trop nombreuses
dérogations reste possible puisqu'ils
touchent uniquement 20 % des projets
l'objectif de fin de vente des véhicules
thermiques les plus émetteurs est fixe
et non en 2025 et 2030
il ne concernera que 1 à 3 % des
véhicules neufs vendus
l'interdiction des vols intérieurs sur
l'alternatif ferroviaire existe ne
concernera l que trois lignes la
suppression des niches fiscales
favorables aux énergies fossiles n'est
qu'un vague objectif alors même que l'on
déplore que 70% du plan de relance est
un impact négatif sur le climat
rien n'est prévu pour concrétiser les
annonces des manuels macron concernant
les petites lignes le fret ferroviaire
et les trains de nuit puisque le
ferroviaire est le grand absent
malgré les efforts de la commission je
dois le souligner
notons enfin un point de grandes
inquiétudes avec la refonte du code
minier ça a été dit aussi prévus
par une simple habilitations plus grave
encore aucune remise en cause des
accords de libre échange n'est prévu il
s'agissait pourtant d'une demande de la
convention citoyenne
aucune de ces mesures ne remettra en
cause dans l'ordre existant avec ce
projet de loi le climat attendra puisque
nous resterons loin des objectifs
affichés
alors même que cette ambition été relevé
par la commission européenne à 55 % de
baisse des émissions
le conseil d'état vient d'ailleurs d'en
joindre l'état de respecter ses
engagements et cela c'est tout récent il
aurait fallu pour cela plus d'ambition
créer de nouvelles ressources pour
financer la transition écologique
prévoir des moyens budgétaires renforcée
mais de cela il n'est jamais question
nous regrettons également que les outils
de puissance publique
surtout que sont la sncf où edf ne soit
aucunement utilisés comme des leviers de
la transition
nous pensons pourtant que la maîtrise
publique des soutiens industriels dans
les secteurs à fortes émissions de gaz à
effet de serre est un gage de
progression important pour la transition
écologique qui constitue par ailleurs
vous le savez un formidable gisement
d'emplois dans un contexte de fort
chômage plus non plus fondamentalement
alors que la convention citoyenne est
censé être une réponse au grand débat
national et donc aux mouvements des gels
et jaune ce texte ne contient aucune
mesure sociale et n'articule pas enjeux
sociaux et environnementaux performances
écologiques et services publics pourtant
nos concitoyens les plus fragiles sont
bien les plus touchés par les enjeux
écologiques victimes de la malbouffe de
l'insalubrité des logements
notre pays compte 10 millions de pauvres
et 12 millions de personnes
nous le savons souffrent de précarité
énergétique l'urgence sociale et
climatique doivent se traiter dans le
même mouvement
une partie de la réponse passe par
l'exigence d'une meilleure répartition
des richesses
mais le texte tout comme la majorité
sénatoriale est silencieux sur ses
enjeux
rien sur le rétablissement de liesse f
rien sur le cicr dont les chez les
jaunes souhaitait l'abrogation la taxe
sur les dividendes a fait l'objet d'un
veto présidentiel tout comme la
conditionnalité des aides publiques
soutenues par les conventionnels
pourtant une politique climatique
ambitieuse nécessite de remettre en
cause les droits acquis des
investisseurs
les intérêts de court terme des
industriels les logiques financières et
commerciales pour y remettre de
l'intérêt commun et protéger nos biens
publics
comment passer sous silence l'étude
d'oxfam qui indique qu'avec le modèle
actuel les entreprises du cac 40 nous
amène vers une trajectoire à plus de 3
degrés 5 d'ici 2100 dans l'esprit des
initiateurs de la tribune
plus jamais ça pour la construction d'un
monstre d'un monde post co vide
nous appelons donc à reconstruire un
futur écologique féministe et sociale en
rupture avec les politiques menées
jusque là et le désordre néolibérale 6
qu'avec mon groupe nous tenterons de
proposer au travers de nos amendements
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur joël
bigot pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains pour sept
minutes
[Applaudissements]
sur le président madame la ministre
mesdames messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues
malgré toutes les précautions de langage
de madame la ministre je crois bien que
nous nous dirigeons vers une nouvelle
défaite dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains que j'ai l'honneur de
représenter ici tu auras bien sûr
d'améliorer ce texte qui ne transcrit
que très fébrilement les propositions de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
sans compter les jokers pavlovien du
président de la république née du
mouvement des îles et jaune cette
expérience inédite de démocratie
participative a fait naître des attentes
et des espérances qui seront déçus en
l'état actuel du texte
missionné par le premier ministre
d'alors noelia sts contemporains ont
planché durant des mois sur la réduction
des gaz à effet de serre sur la justice
climatique avec les meilleurs experts
dont dispose le pays
si bien que le rapport et leurs
propositions concrètes touche là où le
bât blesse
information du consommateur régulation
de la publicité rehaussement des
engagements des entreprises
décarbonation des mobilités rénovation
thermique des logements transition
agroécologiques pénalisation des
atteintes à l'environnement
or nous constatons que la justice
sociale est la grande absente de ce
texte la titulature de votre ministère
devrait pourtant rappeler à chacun la
nécessité d'une transition écologique et
solidaire
le refus initial d'une taxation sur les
dividendes proposés par la convention
annoncé cette coupable lacunes que les
rapporteurs pointe à juste titre une
nouvelle fois ce vendredi dernier lors
d'une audience au conseil d'état le
rapporteur public a estimé que la plus
haute juridiction administrative devait
ordonner à l'exécutif d'infléchir la
courbe des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre produites sur le territoire
national pour respecter les objectifs
que nous avions fixés sous le
quinquennat précédent
cette injonction prononcé juste avant
l'examen de la loi de climat dans cet
hémicycle replace utilement nos débats
nous sommes nombreux sur ses bancs à
espérer des évolutions significatives du
gouvernement et nous représentons une
majorité de français qui souhaitent que
leur pays retrouve la voix d'un
leadership écologique
c'est le moment madame la ministre
d'accorder vos discours d'auto
congratulation à l'efficacité des
mesures de ce texte
d'ici la fin du mois de juin le conseil
d'état pourrait ainsi rejoindre
l'ensemble des organismes consultés
qu'ils jugent plus que sévèrement la
copie gouvernementale
le cee lo conseil pour le climat le
conseil national pour la transition
écologique ont tous désavoué la feb
l'ambition de ce projet de loi au regard
de la sns nbc vous me permettrez madame
la ministre considérait que ces
instances moins conciliante que le
profit que le cabinet d'affaires boston
consulting group sont bien plus dans le
vrai et c'est en s'appuyant sur leur
expertise démocratique et transparente
que nous porterons dans le débat des
amendements structurants quelques
exemples en matière d'information du
consommateur traité dans le titre 1
nous plaidons pour un affichage unique
simple à comprendre pour le citoyen
consommateur désireux de connaître la
valeur environnementale de ses achats
par ailleurs vous ne serez pas surpris
l'inclusion de critères sociaux de
respect des droits humains dans la
fabrication des biens et services nous
paraît essentiel
la responsabilité cause écologique ne
peut s'émanciper d'une responsabilité
sociale qui fait fi des conditions de
travail à l'heure de la case du droit du
travail parle et plateformes numériques
il est temps de redonner aux citoyens
les moyens d'une consommation éthique et
durable
de plus il s'agira d' encadrer plus
farouchement la publicité en dépassant
les simples engagements volontaires
la mise en adéquation des messages
publicitaires et des objectifs de
développement durable et ce quel que
soit le support afin d'éviter un déport
de la publicité carbonées vers internet
parallèlement la création d'un fonds
pour une publicité responsable que nous
défendons pour développer l'éco
responsabilité et influer sur les
comportements
nous insisterons aussi sur les délais
des mesures proposées il est majeur de
les raccourcir pour accélérer la
transition et donner un calendrier de
conversion clair aux acteurs privés qui
sont d'ailleurs nombreux à se saisir de
l'enjeu écologique
néamoins fixer un cap trop lointain
affaibli les stratégies de décarbonation
et laisse trop de portes ouvertes au
détricotage légistique tandis que des
objectifs rappocher oblige à l'action
concrète c'est à la collectivité de
définir la trajectoire
d'où par exemple notre volonté
d'accélérer encore
sur l'interdiction des plastiques à
usage unique ou sur la rénovation
thermique
cela peut apparaître comme une
lapalissade mais nous connaissons bien
ici toute la force d'une date inscrite
dans la loi sur le volet produirait
travailler on ne peut que regretter les
coupes sèches de la majorité sénatoriale
au sortir de la commission il ne reste
en effet quasiment plus rien du dialogue
social des clauses d'insertion dans les
marchés publics
pourtant adopté à l'assemblée ainsi pour
dessiner un chemin différent entre ces
deux majorités nous porterons
l'attention sur le développement de
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui
localement constitue un outil efficace
pour une transition écologique et
inclusive pour anticiper les efforts
nous défendons la création d'une
stratégie nationale concertée de
programmation des emplois et les
compétences de la transition écologique
pour garantir la résilience de notre
système économique
si peut envisager dans ce texte pour la
résilience toujours et la justice
sociale nous souhaitons créer une
garantie emplois verts la démarche des
territoires zéro chômeur entamé sous le
précédent quinquennat a fait ses preuves
nous proposons de nous en inspirer en
développant massivement les éco
activités et à concilier politique de
l'emploi et transition écologique
le titre iii a défini toute notre
attention car les mobilités figure en
bonne place dans les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre favoriser les transports
durables représente un enjeu immense
pour lutter contre notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles développer le fret
ferroviaire et fluvial grand absent du
texte en créant une redevance
kilométrique nationale pour les poids
lourds
renforcer le malus poids des véhicules
réaffirmer le principe du pollueur
payeur actée par la loi 2015 accompagner
les ménages les ménages modestes pour
renouveler leur voiture
autant de solutions portées par notre
groupe
socialistes écologistes et républicains
et qui constitue une alternative étayé
et argumenter face à l'immobilisme
un dernier point je veux bien sûr parler
de l'abandon du crime déco side issue
d'une proposition de notre collègue
jérôme durain le sujet et le respect du
vivant et de l'habitabilité de la terre
ceux qui s'y attaquent doivent en payer
les conséquences pour mettre fin à
l'impunité écologique
à long terme nous serons tous morts
disait keynes pour expliquer l'horizon
temporel des économistes dans le ton du
monde finit donc par les paul valéry dès
nous n'avons pas d'autre moyen que de
ménager les ressources naturelles pour
les générations futures
là elle réalisme écologique là est la
véritable révolution culturelle et qui
pour quelques temps encore échappe aux
tenants de l'immobilisme
nous tenterons malgré tout de vous
convaincre pour que le sénat
s'inscrivent dans la poursuite de la loi
gec et démontre un vin un volontarisme
écologique à la hauteur des enjeux et de
nos objectifs climatiques
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant pour sept
minutes également monsieur didier
mandelli pour les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous y sommes il a
fallu attendre deux ans depuis
l'annnonce de la création de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat en
avril 2019 par le président de la
république pour que le projet de loi
portant lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique et renforcement de la
résilience face à ces effets puisse être
débattu dans notre hémicycle
ce projet de loi climat intervient après
une série de textes qui ont amorcé
depuis plus de dix ans chacun à leur
niveau
la transition énergétique et écologique
de notre pays depuis 2018
nous avons examiné deux textes
importants relatifs à la transition
écologique et énergétique la loi
d'orientation des mobilités et la loi
gek terna retard ce troisième texte
traduit bien sûr l'aspiration des
français à vivre dans un environnement
préservé à se déplacer à consommer
différemment
ils permettent avant tout aux présents
de la république de cocher la case
climat cette transition est nécessaire
mais ça ne doit pas être contraignante
et doit tenir compte des réalités
économiques et sociales de notre pays
c'est la définition même du
développement durable c'est au
législateur que revient la tâche de
définir ce qui est à la fois
indispensable raisonnable acceptable si
la recherche d'un subtil équilibre
nous devons être attentifs afin que la
transition ne devienne l'exclusion
c'est pourquoi le fruit de nos travaux
ne saurait être frappée du sceau du
dogmatisme
je vais souvent dit ici dans cet
hémicycle ce chemin vers une économie
décarbonée respectueuse de
l'environnement ne se fera pas sans
intégrer l'ensemble des acteurs et
chacun de nos concitoyens dans les
réflexions et dans l'action pour en
revenir au texte
je dirais d'abord ce projet de loi
climat souffre de sa construction
difficile et des attentes qu'il a
légitimement susciter la convention
citoyenne pour le climat fait part de sa
déception quant à la prise en compte par
le gouvernement des mesures qu'elle
avait proposé les jugeant insuffisantes
et faisant part d'une forme de trahison
puisque le président de la république
s'était engagé à les reprendre sans
pitre selon l'avis rendu par le haut
conseil pour le climat ce projet de loi
manque de portée stratégique et ne
contribuerait pas à atteindre les
objectifs de réduction des émissions
j'ai pu faire part au garde des sceaux
lors de son audition au sénat dans le
cadre du projet de loi
institutionnels une certaine incohérence
entre la volonté affirmée de modifier la
constitution sur la question
environnementale est ce texte taxé d'
insuffisant par quasiment tous les
acteurs ce n'est donc pas une surprise
si de 69 articles lors de son dépôt à
l'assemblée nationale le projet de loi a
été transmise au sénat avec plus du
triple à savoir les 218 article que nous
aurons à examiner en plus de ce que nous
avons rajouté je profite de cette prise
de parole pour rappeler une fois de plus
que le temps dont nous avons disposé
pour examiner ce texte est tout
simplement insuffisant la preuve en est
que le gouvernement n'a pas eu la
possibilité d'évaluer l'impact
environnemental des nouvelles mesures
votées à l'assemblée
et cela malgré les recommandations du
coup au conseil pour le climat je dois
vous avouer qu'en examinant la nouvelle
version de ce texte
j'ai d'abord été frappé de la faible
portée normative des différentes
dispositions ont un avis très souvent
entre des mesures symboliques ou
anecdotiques pense notamment à l'appui
suppression de la publicité aérienne et
de nombreuses demandes de rapports
l'accord de paris sur le climat à savoir
la réduction des gaz à effet de serre de
40% d'ici à 2030 par rapport à 1990 et
la neutralité carbone d'ici 2050
au regard de la portée normative du tac
semble tout simplement inatteignable
nous avons souhaité mettre l'accent sur
ce manque d'ambition par le dépôt d'un
amendement rédigé collectivement et
porté par la plupart des groupes
politiques avant l'article 1 il n'est
pas dans les habitudes du sénat se
résigner devant un projet de loi dont
l'étude d'impact comporte de nombreuses
zones d'ombré le conseil pour le climat
a demandé au parlement de compléter et
d'améliorer la portée des mesures
c'est ce que nous avons décidé de faire
ici
nous avons souhaité via le travail en
commissions redonner au texte une
véritable ambition en bonne intelligence
et en responsabilité avec les tous les
groupes politiques
nous avons retravaillé chaque aspect du
texte à ce titre je souhaite saluer le
travail des commissions saisie au fond
et pour avis de mes collègues marc à
porter en particulier martha sidrac
finita bord et pascal martin pour la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
qui ont tu n'oublies pas les autres
évidemment je cite ceux de la commission
qui ont eu à auditionner examiner des
positions d'un nombre considérable
d'acteurs plus de 200 au total
je tiens également à saluer le travail
essentiel de l'ensemble
équipe du personnel du sénat la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire développement durable en
particulier avec stéphanie à sa tête que
je remercie pour leur mobilisation
les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes 1960
amendements déposés pour les commissions
697 adopté je n'oublie pas les 1800 élus
locaux qui se sont mobilisés sur ce
sujet via une consultation en ligne
proposée par le sénat si nous avons le
rôle de définir la politique en matière
de transition écologique
ils ont quant à eux la tâche de la
décliner dans le territoire et son force
de proposition ce travail d'écouté et
ses nombreuses modifications permettent
avant l'examen en séance publique de
présenter un texte davantage en
adéquation avec les objectifs
climatiques
je ne reviendrai pas sur les mesures
votées en commission qui ont été
détaillées pour la plupart par les
différents rapporteurs les présidents de
groupe de la majorité sénatoriale
les présidents de commissions et les
rapporteurs ont su traduire la volonté
du président du sénat d'aboutir à une
position équilibrée qui répondent aux
objectifs fixés dans le cadre
négociations climatiques internationales
et aux impératifs économiques et sociaux
les débats qui vont suivre devrait
conforter ses orientations
je vous je m'en félicite je vous en
remercie par avance mes chers collègues
madame la ministre de votre présence est
beau riche contribution
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur
stéphane demilly pour le groupe union
centriste pour sept minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame un ministre
mes chers collègues le groupe union
centriste est globalement d'accord
madame le ministre avec les grands
objectifs de votre projet de loi nous
vous trouvons en courageuse et pugnace
dans cette vaste entreprise ou
finalement vous vous attaquez à juste
titre mur solidifiée par le temps d'un
certain nombre d'habitudes et de nos
comportements dont on mesure dorénavant
vrai sens du terme combien ils sont
inadaptées et néfaste pour notre
environnement
mais car il ya un mais être d'accord sur
les objectifs ne signifie pas être
d'accord sur les moyens de les atteindre
nous sommes dans un hémicycle
parlementaires nationales légiférant sur
des textes concernant 67 millions de
personnes alors que notre belle planète
dont nous partageons tous l'envi de la
rendre plus belle et plus vivable est
occupée par près de 8 milliards de
terriens
nous légiférons donc sur le comportement
de 0,8 pour cent de la population
mondiale alors que l'objet de nos débats
concernent des pollutions qui elles sont
internationales et circule ces cas de le
dire au gré du vent par delà les
frontières
cette lapalissade a pour objet de ne pas
perdre de vue qu'un comportement
nationale vertueux dans un pays aussi
beau et regarder qu'il soit n'aura que
peu d'effets concrets face à l'évolution
du réchauffement climatique mondial et
de ses dramatiques conséquences sur la
biodiversité
mais me rétorquerez vous et vous auriez
raison ce n'est pas parce que les autres
feignent d'ignorer leur responsabilité
individuelle que cela nous exonère des
nôtres même si j'apprécie la métaphore
du colibri de pierre rabhi je pense
néanmoins en l'occurrence que donner
l'exemple ne suffira pas madame la
ministre une fois de plus j'entends bien
le rôle moteur et déclencheur que vous
souhaitez voir jouer dans notre pays et
c'est en cela que je trouve cette
démarche audacieuse et courageuse et
c'est vrai que pour paraphraser
l'écrivain russe léon tolstoï
tout le monde pense à changer le monde
mais personne ne pense à se changer soi
même
néanmoins ne balayons pas d'un revers de
main les éventuels impacts économiques
que peuvent avoir de sage et légitime
décision mais prise de façon solitaire
dans un univers économique
internationale impitoyablement
concurrentiel l'équation n'est donc pas
ça un peu comment agir localement pour
être en adéquation avec ses convictions
et contribuer à donner l'impulsion aux
autres sans pour autant se sacrifier
quand ces âmes notamment sur le plan
économique
dans une discussion générale il me
paraissait nécessaire de resituer le
contexte général des débats que nous
allons avoir en rappelant si besoin en
était qu avoir raison tout seul et loin
de nous garantir une place au paradis
je vais essayer de traduire de façon
plus précise mais propos en 2020 34
milliards de tonnes de co2 ont été
émises dans le monde soit une baisse
historique de 2,4 milliards de tonnes
par rapport à 2019
malheureusement chacun a bien compris
que cette chute n'était pas lié à la
qualité des décisions législatives et
195 pays de notre petite planète mais
bel et bien une situation pandémique
conjoncturelle ou cloître est à domicile
nous avons assisté à une baisse de 3 4%
du pib mondial
du jamais vu depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale cette corrélation avec la tente
entre les analyses environnementales et
économiques apporte d'ailleurs de l'eau
au moulin c'est j'ose dire aux partisans
de la décroissance
nous ne pouvons pas l'ignorer même si
nous sommes nombreux sur ses bancs à
partager le souhait d'une croissance
différente d'une croissance revisiter
une croissance responsable d'une
croissance intelligente d'une croissance
soucieuse du futur mais d'une croissance
quand même en d'autres termes nous
préférons un développement qualitatif
partager à une course égoïstement
effrénée à la croissance quantitative
tel lors du siècle des lumières
nous nous avons joué un rôle moteur pour
dépasser l'obscurantisme et promouvoir
la connaissance
l'idée de jouer un rôle de guide mondial
sur le chemin vertueux du progrès
responsable est assez séduisante et
répondent à l'appel de cohérence de
michel de montaigne qui prônait une
harmonie entre le dire et le faire mais
quand même madame la ministre pour
quitter la littérature comment ne pas
regretter que ce ne soit pas nos
institutions internationales qui
prennent le lead devant de tels enjeux
planétaires
comment raisonnablement tenter de
solutionner localement un problème
planétaire
sans aller jusqu'à la gouvernance
mondiale il est vraiment regrettable que
nous n'ayons pas à minima une approche
partagée décisionnel au niveau de
l'union européenne
cela aurait eu plus de lure et l'effet
d'entraînement où a été nettement plus
contagieux mais là rien notre vieux
continent est aux abonnés absents
il ne peut pas déclencher dynamique sur
le sujet puisqu'il n'est ni exemplaire
ni cohérent ni volontaire ni solidaire
il faut donc encore et toujours remettre
l'ouvragé sur le métier européen et
c'est pour ça que je remercie d'ailleurs
les présidents l'on joue à marseille
d'avoir rappelé par le biais d'un
amendement avant l'article 1er à
l'adhésion déterminé de la france aux
cadres climatique multilatéral qu'elle a
contribué plus que n'importe quel autre
pays à établir
je vais prendre un seul exemple un
exemple lourd de sens notre voisin et
meilleurs alliés européens l'allemagne
qui aimait aller seul un quart des
émissions de co2 de l'union européenne
des 27 a sur son territoire une
quarantaine de centrales à charbon
or je voulais dit lors d'un échange en
commission et j'avais d'ailleurs
initialement du mal à le croire
une seule centrale à charbon allemandes
aimé plus de co2 que tout le trafic
domestique et international de
l'aviation française
tout est dit c'est bien et c'est une
fois de plus louable de dénoncé la
stupidité de maintenir trois ou quatre
lignes aériennes
quand on peut effectuer le même parcours
aussi vite en train sans formalités de
contrôle chronophage sans dépenses
onéreuses de parking en étant
écologiquement responsable sauf que sauf
que ces trois ou quatre os digne
représentant pourcentage 0,0 quelque
chose de la totalité du transport aérien
qui lui même est responsable de 0 8 %
des émissions totales de gaz à effet de
serre 0,0 quelque chose de 0,8 pour cent
ça ne fait pas beaucoup
devant cette décision aux conséquences
environnementales et psylo nesc mais qui
génère des crispations pour des raisons
plus légitime que vous ne l'imaginez
mais nous en reparlerons spécifiquement
lors de l'étude de l'article 36 on est
en droit de se demander si finalement ce
genre de décision ne relève pas du
registre des décisions cosmétiques
madame la ministre je souhaitais dans
cette discussion générale vous alerter
sur les risques que nous prendrions à
être les pionniers de décision les
ultime mais solitaire je souhaitais
enfin vous dire que le groupe union
centriste abordera ce texte de façon
constructive tout en regrettant une fois
de plus l'absence de coordination
européenne sur ces grands enjeux
environnementaux
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur yves
bouloux pour le groupe l'est républicain
pour sept minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues dans notre 20e 20e
signé pardon 20e une siècle le pape
ça commence bien la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
et c'est certainement l'enjeu le plus
crucial pour l'humanité
comment pourrons-nous gérer une planète
portante à peu près 7 8 milliards
d'hommes et de femmes
le climat est une sorte de compteur de
l'ons relève tributaire essentiellement
des activités humaines et de la
démographie
ces deux éléments sont au coeur du sujet
depuis toujours l'être humain cherche à
améliorer son sort
et au fil du temps des avancées notoires
sont apparus cependant c'est avec l'ère
industrielle que le démarrage
exponentielle fut lancé un progrès
indéniable avec les inconvénients du
système tels que notamment les
pollutions et das pillage est désormais
un développement difficile à contrôler
face à une situation considérée
alarmante
le conseil et le parlement européens
veulent parvenir à la neutre et à la
neutralité climatique en 2050 ainsi que
les objectifs renforcés de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
les principaux gta mondiaux d'éclat
également un effort significatif
les états unis ne joe biden le
royaume-uni le canada le japon la chine
la russie
ce sont de bonnes nouvelles s'il est rom
si les promesses tienne quant aux textes
de la première lecture de l'assemblée
nationale donnez moi ma
la ministre mais il laisse à désirer
pour ne pas dire plus un point cocasse
ce texte se veut lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique alors qu'aucune
décision sur l'énergie n'est prise on
retrouve la mauvaise idée de modifier
des dispositions législatives récentes
qui font bien sûr problème comment liger
différé sérieusement dans l'instabilité
c'est pourtant le cas par exemple des
str adepte des zones à faibles émissions
mobilité des galim avec les nouvelles
expérimentations des menus végétariens
le diagnostic de performance énergétique
dpe parmi d'autres les collectivités
territoriales par exemple pour intégrer
un objectif en matière d'
artificialisation des sols devront
revoir leurs documents d'urbanisme qui
ne sera pas sans coûts le logement est
particulièrement important dans notre
société
mais encore une fois on ne prend pas en
compte de la demande de nombreux
locataires rénover les passoires
thermiques est une évidence les comment
quand les aides ne sont pas là par
ailleurs pour les propriétaires
immobiliers surtout copropriétaires les
obligations pèsent lourdement
quant à l'exclusion du marché locatif
des biens classés f et g en 2028
comment va-t-on gérer et financer mais à
25 millions de logements concernés
enfin la ruralité et l'agriculture sont
encore malmené nos concitoyens ruraux ne
dispose pas généralement de transport en
commun ou au mieux le service très
lacunaire par conséquent seul la voiture
permet la mobilité et dans nos campagnes
reculées les salaires sont notoirement
faible
alors si les véhicules plus décarbonés
sont une excellente chose
il faut laisser le temps à moins que le
gouvernement ne décide de renflouer
les émoluments des citoyens pauvres
quant à l'objectif zéro artistes
l'artificialisation net
ce sont essentiellement les territoires
ruraux qui vont être encore perdant
entre en termes d'attractivité et de
développement la plupart de notre
population ne connaît plus l'agriculture
si en d'autres temps de véritables à vue
de pesticides ont existé nous en sommes
bien loin nos agriculteurs font un
travail excellent l'agriculture
française est un modèle mais les
français ne le savent pas alors le texte
de l'assemblée nationale technocratique
quelque peu hors sol avec ses panoplies
de taxes et d'interdits souffle à roland
de gilet jaune
prenons garde le projet de loi arrive ce
jour en séance à la haute assemblée
à l'issue de la première lecture des
débats sénatoriaux il serait étonnant de
trouver un consensus parfait mais compte
tenu de l'enjeu je souhaite vivement que
nous puissions nous accorder au moins
sur les sujets cruciaux
c'est du travail pour le sénat merci
merci je les collègues
la parole est maintenant madame nadège
avait pour le groupe air des pays pour
quatre minutes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les responsables porter madame
la ministre mes chers collègues le texte
adopté à l'assemblée nationale a fait
l'objet d'un des plus longs débats
parlementaires de la vème république
félicitons d'entrée le travail réalisé
par nos collègues députés
nous nous apprêtons à notre tour à
discuter de 1200 amendements dans une
période très particulière
la sortie progressive de la crise
sanitaire et la campagne vaccinale se
poursuivre une autre campagne se tient
également celle pour les élections dans
le département une région
ces collectivités qui jouent et joueront
un rôle fondamental dans cette politique
environnementale
nous porterons avec mon groupe plusieurs
amendements les concernant sur des
problématiques littoral maritime rurale
urbaine
en attendant le texte cadre d une ère
singulière aussi parce que le
réchauffement climatique ne cessera plus
jamais d'interroger les citoyens et les
responsables que nous sommes nous le
savons là encore face à cet autre état
d'urgence ce texte entend apporter des
réponses très concrètes
mon groupe tient pour l'introduction a
salué l'engagement du gouvernement est
le vôtre en particulier madame la
ministre également celui des rapporteurs
et des commissions c'est dit au fond et
pour avis
l'objectif sur tous les bancs et commun
faire de l'écologie
notre quotidien si je puis dire de notre
levée à notre coucher à notre domicile
dans la rue dans les transports au
bureau dans nos assiettes
dans la salle de classe en faisons nos
courses dans toutes nos activités avec
aussi un état d'esprit partagé qui se
veut positif et constructif
traduction de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat ce texte fait suite en
exercice démocratique inédit
certains mesurent certaine mesure par
dont sont déjà actés elle ne relevait
pas tout de la compétence du législateur
d'autres vont être abordés dès ce soir
avec toujours la recherche aussi
nécessaire que difficile d'une écologie
qui ne serait pas punitive mais
incitatives la recherche d'un point
d'équilibré pour que l'environnement et
sa protection ne s'oppose pas au social
à cette autre impératif celui de relever
ensemble les immenses défis que nous
habitions les monts d'arrée l'île de
sein la cornouaille où le centre de
paris il s'agit pour ce faire
d'accompagner financièrement celles et
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
il s'agit d'avancer déterminant en
échangeant constamment avec tous les
acteurs concernés kit oui à s'accorder
sur des compromis
j'écoutais les débats à l'assemblée sur
les problématiques des lignes aériennes
il était marquant de constater les
différences de positions au sein même de
certains groupes parfois où mettre le
curseur
je voudrais alors rappelé ce qui nous
semble être de vérité j'entends que le
sur le sujet climatique nous n'aurions
pas fait assez par le passé je crois que
nous serons tous d'accord pour te dire
que cela est vrai le conseil d'état
vient de le rappeler il nous faut et
nous faudra toujours aller plus loin et
chaque site ça sur chaque texte
mais j'entends parfois aussi que notre
majorité ne serait pas au rendez vous je
ne peux cette fois ci être d'accord pour
la première fois un budget vert a été
adoptée l'année dernière premier pays au
monde à le faire la france une référence
désormais incontournable le plan de
relance
ensuite voté en réponse à cette période
économique si compliqué est rendu
possible grâce à l'action de la france
il porte une part très importante en
faveur de la transition écologique 30
milliards une hausse sensible donc pour
financer des baisses celle de nos
émissions de co2 du rythme de
bétonisation des sols du nombre de vols
intérieurs des véhicules les plus
polluants en ville des logements très
énergivores et il faut le dire nous ne
sommes pas seuls il nous faut nous
battre
à l'échelle internationale la présidence
française de l'europe au premier
semestre 2022 sera l'occasion de porter
haut la voix de la france avec nos amis
européens
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur jean
pierre moga pour le groupe union
centriste pour six minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame monsieur les présidents de
commission mesdames messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues nous y
voici
à l'examen entente entre tant attendu de
la dernière loi environnementale du
quinquennat c'est le cam dition d'encre
et l'écologie dans le quotidien des
français
allons-nous donner examen qui nous
réunira pendant deux semaines sur ses
bases cannes est il réellement
tout d'abord madame la ministre nous
craignons que ce projet de loi ne vous
permettent pas d'atteindre vos ambitions
trop de mesures symboliques
programmatique et pas assez pragmatique
je pense notamment à l'article 10
obligeant à fournir soi même le
contenant est nécessaire au recueil d'un
échantillon commercial il est
incompréhensible de lancer des missions
sur la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments ou sur la publicité sans
s'alimenter le projet de loi alors que
l'examen de celui ci est déjà commencée
enfin malgré un projet de loi passé de
69 à 218 articles des secteurs des
théâtres des thèmes ont été totalement
oubliés
je pense notamment à l'impact
environnemental du numérique à la
prévention des risques au secteur
ferroviaire ou encore à la forêt alors
que celle ci absorbent 11 % de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
au final nous dépistons nous débutons
l'examen d'un projet de loi laissant
planer le doute sur sa capacité à
entraîner une réelle réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre doute
partagé par le haut conseil pour le
climat
le cee ainsi que par la convention
citoyenne elle même dès lors pour le
groupe de l'union centriste
l'examen sénatoriales de ce projet de
loi d'avoir une seule finalité le
réhaussement de son ambition nous
souhaitons résolument nous engager faire
des propositions en ce sens avec une
approche pragmatique par le bilan
carbone afin de réhausser
l'ambition de ce projet de loi est
d'assurer in fine et la crédibilité de
notre pays à damon de la coop 26 et de
la future présidence française de
l'union
nous portons d'une part une approche
territoriale afin de replacer les
collectivités au coeur de la transition
c'est notamment le cas quand il s'agit
du 0 artificialisation net avec une
application différencier et
territorialisée de l'article 29
d'autre part notre approche est
assurément ainsi satie incitatives afin
d'esquisser une véritable écologie
sociale qui veille accompagnés toute
mesure coercitive de dispositifs au
distributif l'exemple des engrais azotés
de l'article 62 et pertinents à une
hypothétique taxation synonyme d'
ultimatum punitif
nous préférons des mesures
d'accompagnement l'examen en commission
a été l'occasion d'apport majeure de la
part du sénat avec la prise en compte
des enjeux environnementaux dans le
cadre de la réforme du code minier
l'ajout de dispositions sur
l'hydroélectricité la structuration de
notre politique de lutte contre la
déforestation importés ou encore la
baisse de tva sur les travaux de
rénovation énergétique dans le logement
social
en résumé si la convention citoyenne
pour le climat a pu démontrer que
certaines formes de démocratie
participative pouvait trouver leur place
dans la vème république
éloignons nous d'un idéal athénien de
tirage au sort
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
n'a jamais eu vocation à se substituer
au pouvoir législatif et le parlement a
dès lors démontré qu'il n'abandonnerait
pas ce computex son droit d'amendement
ce texte nous permet enfin de nous
interroger sur l'écologie et nous
souhaitons pour notre génération comme
pour que nous souhaitons pardon pour
notre génération comme pour les
suivantes
le groupe de l'union centriste défendra
ici des amarres ne m'en correa cohérent
avec une
ligne de crête bien identifiés ne pas
opposer écologie économie réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre saisir
les nombreuses opportunités de la
transition en termes de croissance
d'innovation et d'emploi afin de tracer
un chemin heureux de la transition
écologique
nous défendrons dès lors des amendements
visant par exemple à faciliter la grille
volta volta isme développer le stockage
d'énergie ou encore relever notre
ambition nucléaire sur ce dernier point
permettez-moi une précision face aux
hommes de l'écologie politique selon
lequel il faudrait bannir une énergie
souveraine décarbonés et compétitive en
améliorant l'empreinte carbone de notre
pays uniquement au prix de la
délocalisation de ces émissions
nous défendons la complémentarité entre
énergie nucléaire et les énergies
renouvelables afin de véritablement
verdir notre mix électrique
mes chers collègues le risque politique
réside assurément aujourd'hui dans le
fait de ne pas agir car en matière
climatique personne est innocente
tout le monde de se re victimes et nous
avons tous une part de responsabilité
sans forcément attendre que tout vient
le de l'état puisque en la matière ce
sont d'abord les collectivités qui
doivent piloter la transition écologique
et pour compléter la conclusion d'un
excellent collègue ses fans du midi le
groupe union centriste s'engagera
résolument dans ces débats avec cette
attitude l'envié d'agir collectivement
ambitieusement et de matières
pragmatique je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à monsieur
franck montaugé pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
pour sept minutes chez le président
madame la ministre chers collègues en
1778 déjà le grand naturaliste et
scientifique du fonds écrivait dans les
époques de la nature la face entière de
la terre porte aujourd'hui l'empreinte
de la puissance de l'homme en décembre
2015 la france devenait le temps d'une
conférence le phare d'un monde qui
prenait la résolution de s'engager dans
un changement de paradigme existentielle
pour contenir les effets problématique
du réchauffement climatique sur le globe
terrestre et l'ensemble du règne vivant
pour la première fois de son histoire
l'humanité prenait ainsi acte de son
entrée dans l'anthropocène et de
l'urgence d'une action collective toute
entière tournée vers la durée la
durabilité
depuis dans notre pays des actes
législatifs et réglementaires se sont
succédé beaucoup de déclarations de
communication une programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie une stratégie
nationale balle carbone des filières
industrielles qui infléchissent plus ou
moins activement leur stratégie pour
s'adapter s'adapter aux temps nouveaux
et un constat qui s'impose à tous ça a
été dit à ce rythme là ne contiendront
jamais le réchauffement dans les limites
nécessaires à une planète vivable
à tel point que l'union européenne a
relevé de 40 à 55 % le seuil de
réduction des émissions alors le texte
de nous allons discuter est nécessaire
oui il est important au regard des
enjeux que nous avons à relever
collectivement oui mais il est
d'ambition faible d'ores et déjà les
mesures ne permettront pas d'atteindre
la cible des points 55% de gaz à effet
de serre d'ici 2050
et ce n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
madame la ministre de l'environnement
est le même qui nous l'a confié à
l'audition en réalité et sur le fond mme
pour le gouvernement ce texte est
davantage dictées par la contrainte
extérieure qu'il ne résulte une
stratégie assumée le transformation et
d'adaptation de la société française aux
grandes mutations du monde qui sont à
l'oeuvre
le phare de 2015 est bien pâle
aujourd'hui je crois même qu'ils
éteignent significative à cet égard est
aussi la place qui a été donnée à la
démocratie dans le processus de
concertation si nous trouvons opportune
et bienvenue la méthode d'ouverture à la
société civile qui a conduit aux
propositions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat nous nous interrogeons
sur ce qui restera des propositions
formulées
ce devait être le site du sam filtre
nous constatons que le filtre c'est
bouché entre la convention et
l'assemblée nationale
qu'en est-il aussi dans ce texte la
prise en compte l'acceptabilité sociale
indispensable à la réussite de la
transition
bonnet rouge gilet jaune on a mis sous
le tapis les problèmes le temps que le
soufflé retombe le peuple de la ruralité
le sait parce qu'il le dit au quotidien
rien à cet égard n'est résolu sur le
fond et nous ferons des propositions
pour donner à la ruralité la
reconnaissance qu'elle mérite de la part
de la nation l'occasion nous est donnée
de fonder juridiquement la notion
d'aménité rural j'espère que notre
chambre haute
saisira l'occasion de permettre la
reconnaissance des externalités
positives de la ruralité dont bénéficie
l'ensemble des français de cette
conversion du regard pourraient découler
de nouvelles politiques en faveur des
populations rurales et des agriculteurs
et s'il en est une pour laquelle nous
sommes particulièrement inquiets c'est
bien celle du développement et de
l'accueil des populations nouvelles
en milieu rural le zéro
artificialisation net ne doit pas
annaïg en ile et les capacités d'accueil
des communes rurales françaises sur ce
point la majorité de l'assemblée
nationale n'a pas pris ses
responsabilités elle reste sur une
démarche d'un position verticale
définies par décret échappant donc à
tout débat démocratique une fois de plus
à terme les maires les élus locaux ne
pourront que constater les effets
négatifs d'une procédure et qui leur a
complètement échappé ou le groupe
socialistes écologistes et républicains
ce n'est pas acceptable et ne suffit pas
comme la commission des affaires
économiques de la proposer de
s'affranchir de l'objectif pour que le
problème disparaisse
il faut dans la négociation avec des
acteurs concernés construire un
calendrier réaliste qui nous permettra
d'être au rendez-vous de 2050
c'est possible mais pas avec le texte
proposé nous nous avons été constructif
et responsable sur cette question nous
pensons que la transition l'économie
agricole les aspirations de nombreux
français à la ruralité sont compatibles
et qui doivent être saisis comme une
chance
un levier de développement dans le même
esprit nous proposerons que toutes les
formes de production d'alimentation de
qualité soient mieux retour reconnu en
matière de politique énergétique peut-on
penser un seul instant qu'à reculer
l'affaiblissement d'edf et de ses
filiales nous permettra de mieux
répondre aux enjeux de la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie dont la
trajectoire reste pas ailleurs flou est
incertaine
les mesures d'accompagnement que
contient ce texte ne sont pas à la
hauteur non plus les difficultés du
quotidien que rencontrent beaucoup de
français les aides au logement à la
rénovation font fi des moyennes
nécessaire pour les ménages de condition
modeste
nous ferons des propositions pour qu'il
soit mieux aider la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui est donc aussi celle du
débat public
il faut éviter un rejet de la société la
transition ne se fera pas sans les
français ou contre eux à cet égard le
texte est insuffisant et nous regrettons
que toutes nos propositions visant à
développer le dialogue social est été
rejeté en commission pour terminer je
voudrais avec mon groupe souligner les
grands manques de ce texte des pans
entiers de l'économie générateur de gaz
à effet de serre ont été laissés de côté
la gouvernance envisagée échappe la jma
largement au parlement et aux citoyens
une fois de plus les questions touchant
à la publicité ont été expurgés ou
quasiment
sujet tabou qui illustre parfaitement la
difficulté à prendre en compte la
dimension culturelle et anthropologique
de la transition
la clé de notre efficacité collective
nationale se situe dans le pilotage des
processus
la fixation d'objectifs clairs et
concrets pour chaque acteur à acteurs
les moyens financiers publics
d'accompagnement l'évaluation permanente
l'état doit donc aussi se remettre en
question par rapport aux enjeux de
transformation de la société
la situation budgétaire générée par la
pandémie intenable se rappelle à nous
comment allez vous gérer la dette
publique abyssale la réduire tout en
soutenant les actions les acteurs de la
transition et les français dont la vie
s'est dégradée pendant les 18 mois de
covile le quoi qu'il en coûte qui a
prévalu jusqu'ici va-t-il être prolongé
au service du financement de la
transition du modèle socialement
inclusif que nécessite l'urgence de la
situation et le retard que nous vous
avons déjà pris ou allez vous trouver
les ressources pour mener à bien dans
les temps impartis des transitions à
opérer dans les domaines les plus
contributeurs aux réfugiés au
réchauffement climatique
dans le secteur des entreprises et de
l'économie en général
la préoccupation majeure est à la
relance immédiate et à la résorption de
la dette qu'ovide accumuler alors ce
texte je vous le dis ne pourrait être
dissociée du plan 2 du plan 2 du plf
pardon qui lui donnera ou pas les
moyennes de son existence je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur
etienne blanc pour le groupe l'est
républicain pour six minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues il est tout de même bien
curieux qu'après avoir constaté un
accord quasi unanime sur l' influence
des activités humaines sur le climat à
raison des émissions de co2 et de gaz à
effet de serre que le gouvernement
puisse nous présenter un texte aussi
faible et qui ne répondra pas aux
objectifs qui l'annoncent ce texte il
provient de la crise dite des gilet
jaune
laquelle va engendrer une bien curieuse
institutions nouvelles la convention
pour le climat on dit qu'elle fut
constituée par tirage au sort mais
lorsque le sort ouvre la porte à plus de
50% d'associations de militantes ils
sont proches des milieux
environnementaux lesquels dans une
élection nationale recueille qu'à peine
10% des voix
on ne peut s'empêcher finalement de
penser que le sort a de bien mauvaise
manière pour les grecs dans la
démocratie athénienne
le tirage au sort était absolument
insoupçonnable puisqu'ils n'étaient pas
le fruit du hasard
c'étaient les dieux qui choisissait à la
place des hommes qui ne pouvait pas
choisir
vous ne manquerez pas d'ailleurs madame
la ministre
pendant le long débat qui s'annonce de
nous dire à quel dieu nous devons un
résultat aussi surprenant qu'un probable
mais voici que désormais les tirés au
sort se rebelle
il se rebelle contre un texte qu'ils
jugent notoirement insuffisant les
français pensaient qu'en 2020 le palais
de l'elysée avait enfin trouvé le
système démocratique idéal celui sur
lequel le monde réfléchit depuis platon
et que le génie créatif de la république
en marche avait trouvé la martingale qui
permettait avec un système démocratique
vos de lutter contre le changement
climatique
rien que cela mais patatras cela n'a pas
marché comme prévu mais c'était à
prévoir le constituants de 1958 lui il
avait bien prévu puisque dans
lordonnance du nist 17 novembre il avait
écrit il est interdit d'apporter des
pétitions à la barre des deux assemblées
en fait vous avez confondu consultation
et décision alors le texte que vous nous
présentez contient une foule mesure
anecdotique brouillonne désordonnée
elles sont produites par des lobbys
divers et des associations qui sont
actives mais qui sont issus d'un sort
sur lequel pèse évidemment le soupçon et
puis la mise en oeuvre de cette foule de
mesures nous le savons sera coûteuse
pour des résultats marginaux elle sera
coûteuse parce que le texte contient
plus de 35 mesures d'interdiction sur
lesquels votre administration ne
manquera pas de produire une
réglementation foisonnante
il va bien falloir qu'elle s'assure que
les interdictions et les champions qui
les accompagnent seront bien mise en
oeuvre et en la matière on sait qu'au
ministère de l'environnement on ne fait
pas dans la demi-mesure et qu'en tout
cas on ne manque pas de ressources pour
contrôler la publicité dans les échoppes
et dans les magasins pour dans tous les
domaines forme et sensibiliser éduquer
surtout rééduquer pour inspecter les
cantines scolaires et leur frigidaire
pour s'assurer que les échantillons de
parfum ne seront distribués qu'à bon
escient pour survoler pour surveiller et
contrôler les agriculteurs déjà accablé
par une réglementation qu'il n'arrive le
pas à suivre
vous allez bien sûr créer des postes de
fonctionnaires mais surtout vous allez
produire des normes encore plus de
dorment toujours plus de
le respect du parlement aurait
d'ailleurs mérité que vous nous
fournissent y ait une étude d'impact
précise digne de ce nom pour mesurer
l'ampleur des conséquences financières
de la loi enfin cette loi c'est une
belle occasion manquée vous auriez dû
l'organiser en partant des sources du
réchauffement climatique qui sont
aujourd'hui parfaitement identifié à au
tiers titre d'un tiers environ chacun
l'habitat le transport et l'industrie
en l'état des données actuelles de la
science nous savons que c'est
l'électricité qui permet d'apporter une
réponse solide utiliser directement ou
indirectement avec la filière hydrogène
elle permet des activités humaines
économiques industrielles absolument
neutre en émissions de carbone mais pour
produire cette électricité
la filière nucléaire est indispensable
sauf à poursuivre le massacre de nos
paysages par l'implantation d'éoliennes
produite d'ailleurs pour la plupart en
chine où par la couverture de panneaux
solaires désormais exclusivement produit
en chine
eux aussi puisque la filière européenne
n'existe plus mais hélas les dieux qui
ont influencé le sort de la convention
climat semblait ne pas connaître ou en
tout cas ne pas soutenir cette filière
contemporaine qui est désormais absentes
du texte alors nous allons discuter et
améliorer la loi
nous allons travailler sur un certain
nombre de mesures utiles
l'artificialisation des sols l'éco taxe
régionale ou l'isolation des logements
par exemple
mais d'ores et déjà nous le savons votre
loi n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
et pire encore elle va créer une
nouvelle déception
dans une démocratie déjà si fatigué
merci chers collègues dernier orateur
inscrits monsieur laurent duplomb pour
le groupe l'est républicain pour six
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
il est vrai que sur ce test que sur ce
texte nous pourrions dire un tas de
choses je reviendrai pas sur la
problématique de l'évolution du climat
mais je me focaliserai sur un élément
celui concernant le renforcement de la
résilience
alors je me suis amusé madame la
ministre a regardé la véritable
définition du mou résilience en fait la
résilience désigne originellement la
résistance d'un matériau aux chocs ou
dit autrement la capacité à surmonter
les épreuves et bien cette loi à mon
sens donnent une tout autre image qui
fait comme nous le faisons sans cesse
encore un peu plus de culpabiliser avec
arrogance encore un peu plus de punir
sans discernement encore un peu plus
interdire sans limite et par la peur
alors que pour moi la résilience et je
connais cela puisque dans mon métier
la résilience c'est de semer toutes les
années sans être sûr de récolter et
pourtant de toujours se met la
résilience voudrait qu'au lieu de punir
et d'interdire on se devrait de bâtir et
de trouver des solutions
je prends l'exemple de l'eau pendant des
siècles nos ancêtres ont cherché à la
maîtrise et à la conserver à la stocker
les exemples font légion sur l'ensemble
du territoire le territoire des dombes
les aqueducs romains le marais poitevin
et ben nous dans notre génération et
dans cette loi on fait tous les averses
ont détruit les orages les plus vieux
les seuils qui ont fait la force
hydro électrique du passé par idée
totalement dogmatique
on est contre et archi contre
l'hydroélectricité on refuse de stocker
l'eau pour l'irrigation
on refuse de l'utiliser préférant par
souci de faire comprendre aux
consommateurs aux français s'ils ne
l'avaient pas compris qu'avec le
réchauffement climatique
ils seront sûrs d'une chose c'est
d'avoir soif alors madame la ministre je
ne comprends pas qu'on soit toujours
dans ces interdits le deuxième exemple
c'est que l'on vise sans cesse ce que
nous visons sans cesse comme si c'était
une ligne directrice c'est la
destruction de notre économie
et là on y va par tous les moyens et
tout y passe tous les métiers sont dans
le viseur l'industrie et y'a qu'à
regarder aujourd'hui l'évolution du prix
du métal
vu qu'on en produit plus on la prend
directement dans la figure multiplié par
deux en quinze jours l'agriculture c'est
la même chose on en produit moins donc
on importe ce que nous refusons produire
chez nous et souvent nous important ce
que nous refusons de faire chez nous la
plasturgie
moi qui suis dans un département où la
plasturgie est importante et bien on
préfère le carton et gobelets les
éléments bambou qui viennent de chine
plutôt que de modernisation de notre
activité plasturgie tout ça pour quoi
pour 0,9 pour cent des émissions de co2
en france 0,9 pour cent sur 9 % au
niveau européen
j'aurais envie de dire madame la
ministre vous pourrez obtenir quelque
chose
- on aimait de co2 plus on a une balance
commerciale déficitaire
j'ai plein d'exemples
la france aimez 0,9 pour 184 milliards
de déficit sur la balance commerciale
l'allemagne émet plus de 100 milliards
d'excédents l'italie et mais plus 64
milliards d'excédents donc ni plus ni
moins ce que je regarde c'est que plus
on punit - ont produit troisième élément
c'est que ce sont toujours les mêmes qui
trinquent
ceux qui travaillent l'exemple typique
de ce que vous vous êtes vente et tout à
l'heure la suppression des lignes
aériennes à moins de 2h30 en train elle
concerne climat la ministre
uniquement ceux qui travaillent puisque
par définition celui qui va prendre une
correspondance pour aller aux caraïbes
il aura toujours un avion par contre
tous ceux qui travaillent tous ceux qui
viennent à paris
tous ceux qui ont besoin de se déplacer
ceux ci seront punis et il faudra qu'ils
prennent le train la quatrième élément
c'est la zéro artificialisation des sols
on refuse de regarder les différences
des territoires là aussi c'est pareil du
jacobinisme à tous les étages tous les
territoires sont identiques
donc on fait de l'artificialisation le
cerro artificialisation de partout sans
se poser de questions la ministre vous
avez connu le mouvement des gilet jaune
on reconnaîtra le mouvement des radiers
les rats des champs quand vous aurez à
interdire la campagne de pouvoir
construire qu'est ce qui lui restera de
crever la bouche ouverte comme elle le
fait déjà
cinquième point toujours plus de taxes
et de punition la taxe a ajouté
l'exemple typique encore une une
nouvelle qui nous permettra d'être
compétitifs par rapport à nos voisins et
qui permettra de limiter les
importations est de gagner notre
souveraineté alimentaire alors en plus
de ça madame la ministre vous voulez
mettre une taxe sur la zot
et pourtant vous les voulez faire manger
du végétal à nos concitoyens
eh ben je m'excuse mais pour faire
manger du végétal à nos concitoyens
il faut de la zot parce que j'ai jamais
vu une plante pousse et ce en azote sans
phosphore et ce en potasse et pour la
petite anecdote parce que je les
rechercher
sachez quand même que quand vous mangez
un kilo de salades certes vous n'en
mangez pas un kilo vous mangez dans le
même temps 1500 mg de nitrates
alors que quand vous buvez de l'eau elle
est limitée à 50 mg par litre alors pour
terminer ce que je voudrais dire c'est
reprendre la france la phrase de
pompidou de 1966 mais arrêteront arrête
tes vous donc dans merdé les français il
y a trop de lois trop de textes trop de
règlements dans ce pays
on n'en peut plus laissez les vivre un
peu et vous verrez que tout cela ira
mieux fait
foutez leur la paix il faut libérer ce
pays
voilà la phrase que si tu es pompidou en
1966 et pour terminer commun aller
comment conclure pompidou disait comment
sort mines et comment se ruiner par le
jeu c'est le plus rapide par la
technocratie seul plus sûres bien aller
on reste calme y en a pour deux semaines
1 alors que chacun garde son calme
il va vous falloir des forces il ya deux
mille amendements vous allez largement
avoir le temps de dire tout ce que vous
avez à dire devant naturellement
l'émotion et la passion de tous
madame la ministre vous voulez répondre
je vous en prie merci monsieur le
président j'ai je ne vais évidemment pas
répondre sur tous les points qui ont été
abordés puisque nous aurons comme vient
de le dire si justement monsieur le
président tout le temps de le faire
pendant l'examen des amendements
je voulais tout simplement d'abord vous
remercier parce ce premier bout de débat
qui est déjà très riche et qui est assez
représentatif de ce que nous avons connu
déjà à l'assemblée nationale d'abord
j'ai eu des arguments qui allaient dans
les deux sens c'est à dire j'ai eu des
argument selon lequel ce texte était
trop symbolique ne contenait pas assez
de mesures n'allait n'imprimez passé
n'était pas à la hauteur des ambitions
et puis j'ai eu d'autres arguments
d'autres bancs pour me dire que ce texte
contenait trop de mesures punitives
yves qui a les emmerder les français
pardon du terme ou qui était qui était
beaucoup qui allait faire beaucoup de
victimes etc
on est dans le pur exercice habituel
concernant la question de la transition
écologique c'est à dire et ça a été dit
par certains d'entre vous la question du
curseur comment trouver les solutions
les plus adaptées face à un enjeu qui
nous dépasse tous et je rappelle et je
crois que nous sommes tous d'accord sur
ce sujet que les ceux qui vont subir les
conséquences de ce que nous faisons ça
va être nous un peu mais ça va être
surtout ceux qui nous suivent
et donc nous avons une responsabilité
très forte de trouver des bonnes mesures
pour y arriver
en ce qui concerne les manques qui ont
été évoqués je le rappelle c'est
important cette loi s'inscrit dans le
cadre de réforme plus générale qui ont
été menées depuis le début du
quinquennat et dont d'ailleurs certaines
étaient la suite de mesures qui avaient
été prises avant donc il est normal que
certains aspects ne soit peu pas
beaucoup développée dans cette loi
puisque ils le sont ailleurs
nous avons eu une loi sur les transports
sur les mobilités avant nous avons une
loi sur l'économie circulaire une loi
sur l'énergie
et voilà pourquoi un certain nombre de
mesures sont moins développées mais dans
l'analyse qui a été faite par le boston
consulting group il explique bien que en
regardant l'ensemble des mesures prises
dans le quinquennat tout le spectre de
ce qu'il faut faire pour la transition
écologique et couverts après la question
est il suffisamment passe etc
ça c'est un débat mais en tout cas tout
le spectre est couvert donc on n'a pas
oublié de thématiques ensuite sur les
points qui ont été rajoutés dans la loi
vous avez été un certain nombre à
souligner leur âge ou de mesures lourdes
notamment le code minier notamment
là
la réforme du trait de côte c'est un
choix qui a été fait un choix en toute
connaissance de cause
en voyant la fin du quinquennat arrivée
et en voyant que sur ces deux points
nous avions besoin d'urgence de pouvoir
actualiser notre droit pour pouvoir
faire face à un certain nombre de
réalités qui posait problème
nous avons eu par exemple le problème du
fameux immeuble du signal que bien
connue d'un certain nombre d'entre vous
qui montre la réalité de l'avancée du
trait de côte et des problèmes que ça
entraîne sur les territoires avec le
besoin d'adapter notre droit très vite
il s'avère que nous avons des
parlementaires notamment à l'assemblée
nationale mais aussi chez vous qui ont
beaucoup travaillé sur cette réforme du
trait de côte et donc en finalement les
textes étaient prêts il y avait juste à
trouver le moment législatif pour les
faire passer et donc nous avons saisi
cette occasion qui se présentait à nous
sur le code minier
c'est un sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur
tout simplement parce que comme un
certain nombre d'entre vous ici moi je
suis issu du bassin minier
et voilà je sais ce qui s'y passe je
sais ce que c'est mes grands parents
étaient mineurs tous les deux donc je
vois très bien de sujets actuels et
c'est aussi pour ça que je considère
qu'on ne peut plus traîner pour réformer
le code minier nous avions en plus des
litiges concernant par exemple la
montagne d'or qui est un sujet compliqué
en guyane et qui montrait que notre
droit n'était plus adapté qu'il fallait
très vite l'adapter je crois que nous
avons réussi à trouver un équilibre à
l'assemblée là dessus puisque une grande
majorité des points importants du code
ont été mis en dur dans le texte
l' ordonnance renvoyant surtout à des du
nettoyage de texte j'ai tendance à dire
sur sur la question de qui a été posée
également sur à quoi bon finalement
prendre des mesures dans la mesure où la
france ne représente que 0,8 pour cent
de la population mondiale et que quand
bien même nous ferions nos meilleurs
efforts nous ne pourrions pas à nous
seuls changer là
le cours de du réchauffement climatique
c'est c'est ne pas prendre la mesure de
la place que nous nous tenons
aujourd'hui que nous tenons au niveau
européen et au niveau international
nous avons passé une période de quelques
années où les états unis se sont
complètement retirés du jeu au niveau
des relations multilatérales il a fallu
à ce moment-là prendre la main pour
pouvoir continuer à mener le combat
climatique vis-à-vis des autres acteurs
la france et moi j'en suis très fier et
je pense qu'on peut en être fier
collectivement la france a joué un rôle
dans ce jeu en gardant cette cet enjeu
très fort à l'agenda politique
international
il y a eu des one planet ce mythe il y a
eu les nombreuses réunions
internationales qui ont permis de
pousser cet agenda et la france a été
présente à partir du moment où la france
est présente au niveau international à
une réputation internationale
argument les accords de paris ont été
faits en france à chaque fois qu'on
parle de ses problèmes datent de
réchauffement climatique nous sommes
regardés à l'international et c'est
pourquoi nous devons avoir une politique
cohérente pour ne pas nous retrouver
mis face à des incohérences dans entre
les paroles et des politiques que nous
mettons en place et ça n'est pas si
simple
et enfin nous jouons aussi un rôle au
niveau européen au niveau européen quand
j'entends elle en a pour le coup
stéphane demi avec qui je suis très
souvent d'accord sur un certain nombre
de points là je ne partage pas quand il
dit que l'union européenne ne fait rien
en ce moment sur sur le réchauffement
climatique pardon mais on a vraiment la
nouvelle commission a lancé une
impulsion très forte en lançant en
augmentant l'exigence de baisse de get
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
à 55 % avec un paquet législatif avec
des lois lourde qui vont être prises et
qui vont être proposés au 14 juillet ça
ne s'invente pas le jour de notre fête
nationale qui vont être présentés par la
commission européenne au 14 juillet dans
ses lois il va y avoir des mesures très
fortes qui vont être proposées pour
baisser nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre pour améliorer l'efficacité
énergétique pour augmenter la part des
j renouvelables mais aussi pour
travailler sur l'économie circulaire sur
les batteries sur la relance de notre
industrie est aussi et surtout et c'est
très important sur un prix du carbone et
sur ce qu'on appelle une taxe carbone
aux frontières européennes
avec cette volonté justement que tout le
travail que nous faisons entraîne le
reste tout cela devra évidemment se
coupler avec ce que nous faisons au
niveau international pour aider les pays
qui en ont besoin
donc tout ce que nous sommes en train de
faire s'inscrit dans un creux un cadre
plus global et j'espère que nous
réussirons mais en tout cas la richesse
de ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure et
je remercie aussi le travail des
rapporteurs
parce que le travail qui a déjà été fait
est un travail très importante je
partage un certain nombre de vos avancé
- d'autres qui sont pour moi des reculs
mais c'est tout le débat démocratique et
ça me va très bien comme ça voilà ce que
je voulais dire
en réponse à cette riche discussion
générale et j'ai hâte d'entendre la
suite en espérant tout simplement par
contre que nous laisserons les dieux et
les religions là où ils sont c'est à
dire en dehors de cet hémicycle et c'est
très bien comme ça
[Musique]